Yeah,
it is right.
It's delicious.
Wow.
You recorded one.
Beautiful Jamie and my fucking laptop is
on.
This is my real laptop folks.
You know,
it's not like we have a dedicated laptop
in the studio.
Actually use this laptop on the road.
It's not just here.
Laptop is mine.
It's very important to me.
Tamara,
thanks for warning me about the Werewolf
and they in the lobby.
That's good.
Shit.
Good Shit.
Your pants was eyeballing me speaking to
shit your pants.
I didn't tell you that it was there.
No.
Jamie,
tell us about the law.
The law is shitting your pants.
Uh,
there's a headline here that says,
um,
let me see.
San Francisco,
just San Francisco finally able to ban
people who shit
on the people considered.
Okay.
San Francisco is a beautiful place.
It's a very unusual school.
Ended that corner.
So it's important for a place like San
Francisco to exist to be that far off
the left wing trail.
What's interesting about,
they're really conservative up there
that just conservative liberals.
That's very well put there.
Unbending,
you know exactly what they think on
every issue.
There's this episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
squarespace.com.
Uh,
I don't know if squarespace's in San
Francisco,
but a lot of smart motherfuckers are a
lot of smart dudes up.
Oh yeah.
My rarer brilliant.
Well they got sunnyvale right near there
with all the technical people.
Atherton and I'll let a squarespace is a
website building website.
If you've ever thought about starting
your own website,
just just to fucking write shit down,
just to create a blog just for fun,
just to,
you know,
whenever you know,
make a website with pictures of you and
your friends.
Start a business if you wanted to do
that squarespace's like one of the
easiest ways to do it.
Unlike in the past we had to like get to
know a program and like learn
dreamweaver or actually try to code it
yourself with html,
which is so beyond my grasp.
I don't even,
I wouldn't even think about attempting
to do that.
I know how stupid I am.
But with squarespace you can do it and
it's pretty easy and there's a bunch of
different cool designs and you don't
have to even pay to try it out.
If you go to squarespace.com
forward slash Joe,
you don't need to give them any credit
card.
Just go and check it out.
And if you want to use it,
then use the code named Joe.
And what does it now it's five.
It's fucking May.
May Joe Five.
So that's one word.
It's Joe and the number five together.
So squarespace.com
forward slash Joe.
And the overcoat is Joe Five.
It's a really cool website building
machine.
Really it's,
it makes it so much easier than back in
the design and you can make like a
really competent site and you could
build an online store like super easy to
do.
So go check it out.
You fucks got through it.
That was good.
Do you like that?
I throw that angry part at the end.
It made me legitimate even though I'm
selling them something that ghetto and I
gotta get my street cred back.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
You know,
folks,
there's a certain amount of gross snus
and selling anything and I'll absolutely
admit that there's a certain amount of
gross snus and saying the same thing
over and over again.
Go to ting and tings,
a cool company and sell shit you don't
believe in.
That is true and if I'm wrong about any
of this stuff,
I'll let you know as well.
Like what if team turned out to be evil?
You know,
tim was a secret branch of the
government,
designed to get you more happy with your
phone.
People are getting discontents.
10 came along with a better deal.
Calm everybody down.
Another conspiracy.
People on the phone.
We need him on the phone all the time.
Let's make it cheaper.
Cheaper.
Have you ever met anybody through a way?
You wouldn't have to even it with
somebody,
but the idea like because I suffered
from online people meet black people
have one commercial that you see that
no.
What is this place for black people to
meet black like a website.
They're so hard.
Why don't you just go to a black
neighborhood,
go to a bar.
They have a website.
Well,
if it's,
you know,
nothing wrong with being specific,
I mean,
if can't imagine,
Italians don't think so.
There's got to be an Italian is looking
for Italians website.
This guy.
Yeah,
because Italians love other Italians are
an Italian girl.
Oh,
they're the worst to the best of the
worst.
Be related to the savages sexually.
They're fucking animals.
Oh my goodness.
They're fucking beasts.
They're,
they're like,
they're.
Yeah.
The savages.
They are savages.
I liked the,
I like a girl who's not like me.
The liquid.
We used to say she's a good kid.
She's a good kid.
But the last,
the tiny girlfriend I had,
she's like,
she's likely to swing at me.
No.
Should we get crazy?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's what my friend said to me about
it.
He said,
I've never cheated on my wife.
I'd be afraid to stab me in the neck.
I was asleep.
You know,
this is a girl like del girlfriend the
last.
That was the last one.
I was like,
you though.
Yeah.
I was like,
I think I was 21.
She was great kid.
Beautiful person,
but they're just,
wow.
I keep in touch with her.
No,
I do not know.
I do just testing you.
A Tang is the other podcast.
Sponsor Tang is a cell phone company
that uses sprint backbone and what it
does is they.
They have it set up so there's no
contract,
so you can quit anytime you want.
You buy the phones.
The phones that they sell are the best
android phones available.
They have all the high end android
devices including the Samsung Galaxy
note to which is this crazy fucking
phone.
I've never seen this thing before.
It's.
It is preposterous.
It's gigantic preposterous phone.
It's the one that starts your car and
all that does is sets the climate and
the car,
like if it's cold,
so ridiculous.
It starts your car.
How is that possible?
Is that really possible?
And App it starts your car.
Oh yeah,
because there's remotes for awhile
because they.
They would do it like in like in
Montreal called places Tom Around.
I'm not ready for this yet.
I'm not ready for apps to start your
fucking car.
I'm not ready for that.
That's too much.
Car pulls up.
Get in Joe.
Google cars,
they're doing that already dumb.
They already have these remote control
cars and they drive around the city and
they drive themselves.
They react to cars coming at them.
They haven't even been getting in
accidents.
It's nuts.
It's fucking nuts and I still wouldn't
trust it.
Well,
I can't imagine sitting in the back
seat,
but my car driving itself,
there are a lot of fucking assholes out
there,
Tom that drive cars.
There's a lot of fucking assholes.
I saw some kid the other day just
weaving in and out of traffic.
Speeding.
He was flying past people in like a
real,
like arrested while he was in the wrong
place at the right time,
you know,
he was doing the wrong thing at the
right time.
There's no cops anywhere by him,
but with the way he was driving was like
really crazy aggressive,
like cutting people off and racing in
front of him.
It was dangerous.
Like he was like,
he was cutting like random strangers,
like off,
like barely missing their car.
It was kind of maniacal to walk like
every now and then you just get a person
like that.
It's just really crazy article about
teenagers that their brains aren't fully
developed and there's a reason to get in
so many accidents because their
perception,
the reactions are good physically,
but they make wrong choices.
Terrible choices.
I was a terrible driver when I was a
terrible,
terrible driver.
Now see me drive.
Don't even watch.
Could pull it off.
Would you be happy if Google came along
with something that you can say,
take me home and the fucking robot call.
That's common mind mind.
If I open up a six pack,
I would definitely.
If you're drinking and driving and your
car,
your car is driving itself.
Can you still get arrested?
If it's a very good question because you
would have to.
It would have to know for sure.
You know where you're going,
right?
No,
you wouldn't.
You couldn't tell it to,
hey,
go fucking driving the wrong lane of
this street.
I mean,
we would have to be some sort of.
It would have to have a.
A thing that said it couldn't do it,
so there wouldn't to be.
How does it know when there's a light to
turn green?
Has It?
No one,
there's a light turns red and it's going
to have to be plugged into the whole
system.
Now there's going to be have to be,
you know,
if you really think about it,
it's going to have to be like a wifi
network or something everywhere that
controls these cars.
I mean they would have to have real
control to to let a car go and just
drive around with no person touching the
and make sure that it stays on path.
Wow.
I would think that would be really hard
to trust.
I mean,
I don't know how you controlling it.
I don't understand what's.
How's it getting to it?
It's got to get there from the cell
phone has got to be some sort of a
signal that's reaching the car.
Unless the car is just a robot,
a self sufficient robot,
which is even crazier.
That means no one is controlling it.
That means it just goes on what it knows
about what's in front of it with radar
or whatever.
It's using sonar.
I don't know when it's using who.
That's crazy.
That's kind of nuts at the end.
If that happens,
that's an APP that you get the fucking
take download Merera home app and you
press that or your phone and your
fucking car just drives you home.
Why is that so weird to me?
Of course that's coming,
right?
Take me home while you hungry.
That's all,
isn't it?
It's coming.
It's amazing how technology has advanced
so much in the last five years we had
panic attacks.
If we forget our cell phone now I have a
panic attack.
If I forgot my cell phone.
Yeah,
and you know it's.
It's so valuable for finding shit out.
It's so valuable for like going on
websites to read anymore because they
can get the answers at their fingertips,
slept well.
It's not that you don't have to read,
but man information is flowing so much
quicker now.
Like if you knew you had a question for
Google,
it'll be like a really hard thing to do
to research the question and there was
like a lot of people who developed some
really good bullshit arguments back in
those days and the they don't hold up
anymore because of Google.
Wikipedia is not necessarily always
right over here in the argument.
Yeah,
there's always a.
yeah,
that's a.
that's a big one.
People love to say that there's,
but there's always gonna be people
downplaying it,
but the bottom line is it's no one knows
everything.
It's impossible and you could find some
more and more things because of this.
Like,
this is amazing.
This is a great time to be alive.
This is your phone.
You fucking pick up your phone.
Do you talk to him?
Tell him to go to websites for you.
I mean,
this is where we.
Have you ever used that google voice?
Oh yeah.
He beat the shit.
You press it and you say dom irrera and
it'll go right to your website.
Pulls up.
I liked the one where you'd go call
called Joe.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
They go,
yeah.
They,
almost all of them also have the ability
to read text so you can,
you can talk to it a write shit down for
you,
which is a really helpful,
like you ever used that?
Um,
that note thing on the iphone.
Uh,
yeah.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
You can talk to it dom,
like I can press this button and say my
rare is a bad motherfucker and it
literally will say,
damn,
I rare is a bad motherfucker.
I was trying to get a porn this morning.
Oh,
you said it was on your phone.
They'll know a direct TV and it was
because it was cougars seeking kittens,
which I don't know.
I find very erotic.
Like the older women that like young
girls.
Really?
Yeah.
So I'm looking at the fucking thing.
Wouldn't listen to my phone number.
I kept saying six,
nine,
four.
She goes six,
nine,
five and then I'm getting mad at the.
When you open up your fucking years,
six nine for you fucking Douche bag.
This is what you get for trying to buy
porn.
I know why you're trying to buy porn.
It was super specific.
Yeah,
and I just think I'm too lazy to
download it and Shit.
I hear you.
It's always much easier to use that
credit card.
Yeah,
it is because they just send it to your
bill.
You don't even have to read the letters.
Go Rogan.ting.com.
And Save Twenty five bucks.
It's a credit.
What is the jail cell phone company with
no contracts?
I like to know contracts and because
that's another commitment in life.
I'd rather not me.
Why do you need it for cell phones?
That always bugs me.
That's gross one.
And they keep adding a couple of years.
Every time you take it back to you
motherfuckers.
Dom irrera team doesn't do that
conspiracy.
They also,
they save you money on a bell by if you
don't use,
like if you use under your minutes,
they credit you the difference in the
next bill,
they bump you down to a lower level and
they credit you the difference.
So it's an awesome company.
The grant a,
check them out on it.
Dot Com is our last sponsor.
If you go go to o,
n n I t if you haven't been there in a
while,
there's a lot of new shit,
especially in the strength and
conditioning department.
We have these primal bells now,
which are insane.
They're the coolest fucking Kettlebell
and the history of the universe.
Um,
we uh,
had the idea of doing kettlebells with
these evil chimpanzee faces on them.
And this,
uh,
this chimpanzee's face.
Can you pull that face up?
Jamie Chimpanzee's face?
It just looks like he's about to fucking
kill you.
Can you see it?
Oh,
I see.
I love that thing because when I work
out with it,
I pretend that I'd have to fight that
thing to the death.
That's what I do when I work out.
What's the fear of God into you?
It was amazing how much stronger they
are.
The not.
It's not even.
It's we're so silly because they look
kind of the same size as us.
She gets super confused,
but we are made out of Jello.
Okay.
And that,
that thing is coated steel.
The chimpanzees are stupid,
strong,
like we can't even get it around our
head.
It's,
it would be so strong that once it
grabbed a hold of you,
you would feel so helpless.
You'd feel so helpless.
A 150 pound champ was like a 500 pound
man.
I've written one that ate that woman's
face.
Oh Jesus.
There's so terrifying.
These fucking things.
So to have one as a Kettlebell is the
shit son and it's only 36 pounds and
you're like,
Joe Rogan,
I aint no pussy.
And I'm like,
dude,
I didn't say you were.
But the reality is I have a workout for
you that will work with that 1:35
pound Kettlebell.
I guarantee you it'll kick your ass.
So the extreme kettlebell cardio DVD,
we sell it on a,
on a.com,
and we have the new one extreme
kettlebell too,
which I haven't done yet,
but I'm sure it's awesome.
That Guy Keith Weber is a bad
motherfucker and it's a great way to
like you forced yourself to just keep up
with them.
Just force yourself to do what he's
doing and it'll just kick your fucking
ass.
I'm built like that under my president
buddy.
I know dumb or wherever you're in the.
It's in the right underneath my layer.
We're going to get you a using the
fucking medicine ball,
doing some body weight squats,
dot Merera,
Eaton Alfie.
Cheers to that to talk,
talking healthy drinking beer.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's debt deschutes brewery,
black butte porter.
That stuffs that shit.
I said I said black but black but
stupid.
How dare you.
But let's basically it should be like,
but t t e,
why is that butte?
Why is it because the White House,
the street not called Houston Street.
That's a good fucking question.
God dammit.
I got questions as well.
I got a lot of observations like other
comedians.
Really.
Mine are funny.
Just observations.
Someday I'm going to upgrade them.
We're going to end this commercial right
here.
Now this was a commercial for the
kettlebells for everything.
For Life.
So it was tin Kettlebell on his for life
dot Merera.
Yo.
That's might be the Douchey Shit I've
ever seen in my life for life,
for life.
If you already starting to call it.
That's how you say it,
but the reality is you have a cult.
This is a podcast.
Okay.
This is a.
we're selling healthy food.
That's all done,
but this is not me live with following
like a cult phone.
I'm a part of something that's not
undermine my railroad slot into my
control.
Use the code name.
Rogan.
Yeah.
If you use a code name,
Rogan,
you save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
Just go there,
check it out.
Luggage stuff,
healthy stuff for you.
And cute music.
Jamie,
the great domme.
Motherfucking rarer is here.
Joe Rogan podcast.
My long time friend,
one of my longest friends in the history
of my life.
Diamond.
I had been friends for shit,
it's been at least 20 years now.
We're,
yeah,
it's crazy.
It was 20 years,
right?
And we get you up in Montreal.
That's the first time I remember.
I think it was 93.
Yeah,
I think that was 93.
And then we met in uh,
Amsterdam billiards.
And uh,
you know,
we talked for a little bit.
I didn't know you played football and I
was all excited.
There's only a few of us that play pool
like Ferrara and for our place.
Really good pool.
Emonds fitzsimmons plays really good
pool.
Already.
Plays Good Pool.
Yeah.
I would get so excited.
I remember bringing you up thinking this
is a new breed of convenience.
This kid looks like a fucking tough kid.
Even when I didn't know you were in the
martial arts,
just thinking.
I mean you were funny.
You were always funny.
I'm not just stroking you,
but remember bringing it up,
thinking st the fucking kid who had
problems with his mother talks about is,
you know what I mean?
Because it was a different.
I told you this before,
you're a group of comedians were like
more tougher men.
I grew up in a lot of like nebbishy
Kinda.
Well I,
I grew up doing comedy.
I started out in Boston and that,
those guys that's particularly meeting
ground.
Yeah,
they are particularly manly.
You know,
who made me think that I could do it
honestly,
like who?
It didn't make me think that the way I
looked would be an impediment was nick
Depaulo oh,
okay.
Because Nick Depaulo was great head of
hair,
so fucking devastatingly handsome guy
who's way better looking than me and he
was bigger than me.
It's a big,
like a football player.
Yeah,
he was,
he was hilarious and I was like,
it was a weight off my shoulders because
I remember thinking that I looked like,
like an athlete or something and it
looked like a jock,
you know,
if you look at good jock,
like you automatically categorized and
it automatically makes you less funny.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's definitely.
I mean there's like,
look at Gary.
Gary Goldman.
Yes.
Perfect example.
Beautiful Man to talk to.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Perfect.
He's cute.
You don't like about hips?
Got Beautiful.
Fucking devastatingly handsome,
man.
He's big,
handsome.
One time.
Kightlinger.
He's Hunky.
He's,
I'd like to take into a prison cell.
Uh,
Laura Kightlinger,
right?
We're an Ireland.
Remember?
Sure.
Yeah,
very funny.
Very pretty word.
She's dressed.
It looks like a fucking model and she's
dying on stage and she's really fun.
She goes,
what happened?
I go,
you look too good.
The guys can't laugh at you.
The girls don't think you're funny
because you're too pretty and the guys
can't live because their girlfriends or
looking at them,
see if their left and looking at you.
Do you know Brian Frazier?
Do you remember?
Brian Frazier from Boston probably
stopped doing standup,
but uh,
he,
he writes,
we,
I haven't spoke to him quite a bit,
but uh,
he at one point in time was enormous.
He was a bodybuilder and he,
I mean he was super.
He like,
he's one of those super dedicated super
disciplined dudes that can force himself
to work an hour and a half a day and eat
strictly healthy.
He was fucking drunk.
I mean,
he was huge.
Then you would go on stage with like a
golf shirt on and I had a poem sign,
Dude,
you can't wear that.
Right?
And he's like,
why?
And I go,
because you're too big.
I go,
trust me,
you got to try to stay in this.
I guess I go,
dude,
I,
you know,
you're my friend and uh,
you make me nervous.
Like you're fucking arms are gigantic.
They had like bouncing in his arms.
They were too big.
He couldn't stop.
He couldn't not look at them.
How about Pisco?
And he got,
let me know those things at the carnival
where you stick your head into the
muscle man's body.
Yeah.
That's episcopal look like,
yes,
no,
no.
Brian Frazier was bigger than him.
I'm telling you.
Was the big no,
he was.
No,
no,
no.
It's Pisco.
Maybe.
Yeah.
But frazier was just like super
dedicated.
He was like crazy dedicated.
Here's a funny fucking story because he,
he,
he's a really funny guy and he looks
like baby,
like an Irish guy from the midwest,
but he's Jewish and he's,
he at this time had like a really
fucking.
He's,
you know,
he's got a temper and he doesn't like
people fucking with them,
you know,
he was,
I mean,
he and I never had any problems,
but he was a at a Gig and Vermont once
and we would get,
we worked together up there and um,
that he had a little bit of a problem
with his voice.
He had a little bit of a cold and so he
was saying to the,
uh,
to the,
owner of the club,
it was like apologizing for his,
uh,
his voice being a fucked up.
And the guy who owned the club said
something like,
you know what,
what are you being a Jew or something?
Ooh,
something along those lines,
like you sound like a Jew because he
didn't think he was Jewish.
It was something along those lines.
It was like really crude and you're
like,
and Brian went fucking crazy.
He went crazy.
It was a desk between him and the guy
and that's probably the only thing that
stopped him from smashing this guy,
but he was so scary because he was like
really fucking strong.
And I remember thinking like,
because back then like I didn't even
lift weights,
like I would die.
I never lifted weights to my window
days.
I was like,
I was pretty skinny in comparison.
He was like way bigger than me.
I was like,
God damn,
I don't know if I can stop him from
hurting this guy,
you know,
because he's just so much stronger than
him.
He could just run right through them
like a bowl.
But that one thing the guy said to him
like,
don't be a Jew.
Like what are you being a Jew?
I forget,
I forget what it was,
but I remember like going,
Oh shit,
like that's the moment where you're
trying to talk your friend at a doing
something really stupid or the moment
like,
I know how you feel,
I know how you feel and your right to be
upset,
but please don't do anything.
Let's get the fuck Outta here.
If you do something right now,
that's going to be stupid.
It's a mistake and it's going to fuck up
your freedom.
You're going to get locked in a cage.
You're not going to do this.
There's now civilized people do keep the
fuck away from people if you don't like
them,
but you don't have to beat him up.
You know that.
That gets weird.
I,
I know when you get that look that you
are thinking,
but you don't go into action.
Remember one night we were drunk and
kids came up to the pool hall and one
kid just fucking lit you up and I just
looked at you at the.
I know he ain't going to lose it,
but this kid has no idea that fucking
dangerous.
Well,
he was.
I remember what you're talking about.
It's just drunk men.
Yeah,
I mean I couldn't imagine what it's like
to be a woman and deal with the drunk
man wanting to hold you down and fuck
you in the same type of like you would
just run into people that are just.
The name did not like that when they're
sober.
I don't know.
I mean some people just have a problem
with drinking.
They just get weird,
but when you're around him,
like aggressive drunk dudes.
It's so unfortunate.
It's like,
oh,
what a fucking predicament.
This has got to suck to be a check.
Then they start repeating themselves
and.
But I always say,
look,
the law,
it doesn't bothers me a little bit,
but at least it's not threatening like
it as to a check.
I really always think about that when I
see those kind of really drunk,
Douchey guys.
It's gonna be a terrifying thing to have
a guy you know want to hold you down.
Fuck you.
It is.
It's got to be awful.
Tell me the story.
Tell me the truth.
That's terrible.
I can't take it anymore.
My back's killing me when you were
saying that thing about,
you know,
it's kind of fucked it that still
around,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I with my God daughter living with me,
I can't sleep unless she's home.
You know what I mean?
And like honestly my Godson,
he's closed blood.
If he got blown at a party by the kids'
mother through the Party,
I'd go dad that much.
Tell me about it and don't read it.
Don't wrap the lady out here.
But you know what I mean?
It's like,
it's so different with girls.
It's totally different.
I was thinking of something you said
before about when he said he was,
the guy was Jewish and he didn't know
how you're part of your culture,
your party background.
I was married to a Jewish woman,
right.
And I one day I said not meaning it in
anything,
just my own ignorance.
I said,
yeah,
maybe we can do.
We can do the guy down.
And she said,
that's really insulting.
I go,
why?
And she said she explained it to me.
So then I just start saying,
let's Christian that motherfucker down
just to,
just to bring it back on myself.
That's funny.
<Unk> frazier
got mad at me for using that expression
of that guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean they get mad at me,
like threaten me,
you know,
we were friends,
but he's like,
you know,
that's really a rude thing to say in
Atlanta.
But I was like,
you know,
I've always said it.
I never thought of it.
I didn't even think of as a bad thing.
I was like,
you know,
guys got gold chains on always Guinea
and ended up,
yeah,
no,
you want to get some money on jus the
guy down it.
I didn't think it was bad to be frugal.
No know
I never connected the two.
I never meant it as a set it.
And then I saw that it was obvious once
he said,
I was like,
yeah,
I guess that is pretty insensitive.
Do you know that they,
they got a guy today,
95 years old who was a Nazi at the one
of the camps,
95 native rest of them.
I think you think he's gonna get life,
but,
but seriously it's.
Did you see it and say that's a terrible
thing for Karma?
That tech.
I lived that large and Tina,
he had 95.
That was a big thing they said.
He said he would.
Yeah,
they all went there.
He said he was a cook at the camp
concentration camp.
God.
Yeah.
You know what's scary about the Nazis is
that that that shit was not that long
ago.
These guys are still here,
still alive.
So most of them are still.
Well,
that's why I think about when,
when Mel Brooks did the producers how
fresh that was.
I mean,
how fucking ballsy was that.
Don't be a dummy.
Bah Marty.
Come and join the Nazi party.
Remember when they were doing the goose
step dance.
You remember the movie and I was
thinking that was in the sixties and the
war didn't until the forties.
40th five,
seven.
I think it was.
It was.
It 47,
so I thought it was 45 or whatever.
It wasn't that far back and he did this
whole thing about Hitler.
It was fucking hilarious.
And total balls.
Oh yeah,
no,
it was 45.
It ended malpractices.
Bad motherfucker still is.
Still is.
Apparently Brian Callahan knows him or
knows.
Oh No,
no.
It's Fitzsimmons fits fitzsimmons.
Taoism says a guy just fucking hangs
around because they don't go to a coffee
shop and talk to him.
I met him in the street,
like a super personable guy.
Just a real nice guy enjoying life.
His fucking son is a bad ass author.
His son is the one that wrote that World
War z movie.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
His son wrote the book,
which I guess a lot of people.
I haven't seen the movie yet obviously,
but a lot of people are pissed that they
deviated from the book.
Sometimes they do that,
but uh,
yeah.
It's his son's band as author.
He did two of the funniest movies ever.
Young Frankenstein producers blazing
saddles.
Three to three movies.
Movie Young Frankenstein was fucking
hilarious at the time.
He was a.
He was the man,
I mean if you went to see a mel brooks
movie,
like there's really no one to compare it
to today because he would act in them.
He would.
I always had to sing or something like I
saw high anxiety.
Yeah,
they was singing like a lounging land
singer.
He's got high anxiety and he goes it
each time you are near the idea of Zion.
So fucking stupid.
Mel Brooks was a genius man.
He was a powerful,
prolific genius.
He tells a lot of really good stuff.
At the time was him and woody allen kind
of like in.
I don't know.
It was more silly.
Yeah.
That's pretty fucking silly.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
I love the one where he's playing the
cello and I'm marching band billy has to
run up and sit down for a couple of bars
there.
Take the money and run.
If you've seen a mel brooks history of
the world.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's funny,
man.
It's beautiful stuff.
At the time,
like I was just,
there was nobody.
There is nobody else like that.
Making movies like that.
It was like you heard it was a mel
brooks movie.
You knew you were.
It was a certain standard.
Yeah.
Comedy that you're going to get.
It's great stuff though.
They could never make blazing saddles
today.
No,
they couldn't.
Just political tubes.
Racially charged.
Yeah.
I mean there could never be an all in
the family today.
It's true.
Yeah.
I don't.
I don't believe that.
And it's sad.
It's sad that people would,
you know,
the good thing is,
look,
it sucks that people like that ever
exists,
that there really could be a guy like
archie bunker that's at racist.
Yeah.
But it's still fun.
My uncle was like that.
We had family members that were like
that.
There were people that were worse in
that by the way,
like way worse than you wouldn't even
give black people credit for being good
looking.
You know what I mean?
Like if a black woman was beautifully
go,
that's a white nose.
She got a white note.
You know what I mean?
Like she,
he bring up for white people are
beautiful and like that's fun,
but it was real.
You know what I mean?
He hate,
he hated like,
you know,
cause I was a kid,
I grew up with the Beatles,
he hated the Beatles.
He hated like anything rock and roll
that was ruination of the world.
Well,
you know what time I think I used to
wonder what the fuck that was all about.
And I think what it really boils down to
is that people have these weird natural
tribal instincts.
They have these weird tribal instincts
and they belong to a tribe.
And whether that tribes being a
republican or would that tribe is
listening to classical music,
you know,
wherever the fuck it is that they decide
this is where they draw the line.
This is where they stand.
It's a tribal thing.
You know,
it's,
it's a weird deviations of our need to
form groups,
you know,
so we'll get upset about shit that
doesn't matter even a little bit.
I try and not be stuck in any one area.
You know,
the only thing I was thinking,
I don't even know if this is funny or
not,
but where's,
what's gonna Happen in the rock and roll
hall of fame in 15 years?
Like when there's no groups left and
it's like,
rap music is dominant.
Hey,
you know what I mean?
Like,
because they're going to be like a
motherfucker.
This motherfucker minimally.
No,
not like any rap music.
I do kind of like.
Well,
I mean I like,
I like what's snoop?
Snoop is great.
I think I like m and M.
I love some of the music.
What would you like by m and M on
itunes?
Yeah.
I couldn't imagine seeing dot Merera I
get brought up to date.
What do you want to lose yourself?
You lose yourself.
Yeah.
So that's fucking great.
In the beginning is great.
And uh,
just,
you know,
when you get one chance in a lifetime,
don't blow it.
Yeah.
No,
that's a beautiful song.
Yeah.
Now he's a bad motherfucker.
I'm an alum and I liked the one mama
never meant to hurt.
You never met.
I'm cleaning out my closet is pretty
fucking great.
Fucking songs coming out soon.
Does it really good for him,
man?
He's brilliant.
Yeah,
I think he doesn't like to perform.
I heard that.
That was a problem that doesn't like to
go outside.
Well,
you know,
I mean then yeah,
I'll fucking famous,
don't do this.
You know,
he got so famous.
I mean he got crazy famous.
He got famous to the point where it's
probably probably fucks with your head.
Yeah.
We used them.
I was thinking last time we were
shooting pool and you're very good with
people,
but the guy got on your nerves because
joe was just,
we getting tired and we both,
both of us were kind of tired and you
said I'm a fucking wreck in the balls.
He wants you to take a picture.
She was like,
that made a,
there was no good tie.
The poor guy.
I mean he was,
you were nice to him anyway,
but I just knew you weren't in the mood
for.
It's just drunks in that guy
particularly.
That was no big deal.
Yeah.
That was just,
you know,
someone was just enthusiastic and want
to take a picture.
That's all good.
It doesn't bother me at all that what
bothers me is that the drunk thing where
you know,
the drunk close to your face,
that clunky,
repetitive,
they grab you.
I really liked that.
Grabbed my neck again,
I go for the I'm,
I'm cool with everything,
but the drunk thing and if it seems like
you're drunk,
it's like,
Ooh boy.
I don't know.
He drunk to.
How close do I get to a stranger?
You know?
He'd never seen me drunk A.
I've seen you drunk as soon as jack at
the laugh factory.
Really?
Yeah.
How long ago?
At least an hour ago.
An hour to go and I think he's seen me
drunk.
Yeah,
it was.
It was months ago.
Many,
many months ago.
One of the last.
I mean I've only been at the laugh
factory and maybe three or four times
over the past decade.
You're not going to come back?
No.
I would come back Wednesday night.
Show mine.
I'll do whatever you're doing.
If you're doing shit there,
I'll be happy to do your fucking balls
with them.
I'd be happy to do it because they are
likely to do the half hour at the end.
Then we have the interview.
Yeah.
That was fun.
You had a great crowd.
It was.
There were smart people,
you know.
That was a.
That was a fun crowd,
but I've been.
I've been to the laugh factory.
I sent like four or five times.
One of those times you were drunk.
You motherfucker.
I was drunk.
What stage?
No,
no,
none unstable.
One time.
One time on stage.
I was drunk because I said something and
then when I realized I was drunk I said
something to go know what the fuck you
talking about?
He would say like in an attacking way,
they like confused and I realize that.
Fuck you.
He gives me an Irish coffee.
You can't give an Irish coffee with half
that.
There's so much whiskey.
The coffee's cold.
Oh,
is that what he did?
Yeah.
And I'm taking flight training to have
them look up to a damn.
So what does that like five tanks?
Probably five whiskies.
Yeah.
Shots.
At least that links my balls hurt.
You say that like,
Oh,
what else makes you out to a restaurant?
Lists that would.
A friend of mine,
you know,
there's guys that make everything
sexual,
like whatever.
And the waitress was fish was taken
along and get you some Zucchini sticks.
This has nothing to do with sex and when
she walks away,
he goes,
I'll give you the Zucchini stick.
Fucking.
It'd be like not to do with any of the
tubes that always have that I gave you
want a sandwich?
Yeah,
I'll give you a fucking sell meat ball
right here.
Like I said,
I'm glad I'm a girl.
I'm bleeding that a girl to be fucking
scary.
I never seen a girl.
It's such a defined back.
I've seen them.
I've seen some big ones,
but the one who came out last week,
she's got an Adam's apple,
who's,
I forget her name,
that she just went into the pros.
Just the.
I think her team won the national
championship.
Brittney griner?
Yeah.
When you're going into the pros for what
she was saying,
she.
She's got like a beard on her dick.
So fucking.
She's so mad.
She came out of the closet.
Who is she?
She's.
She was.
She's like the all time shot blocker in
the NCAA,
the women's division.
She is like a maze is basketball,
but I mean the thing is it was nothing.
It meant nothing to anybody.
Then the guy comes out,
the seven foot guy,
the twin,
which he didn't tell his twin brother
who was gay.
Did you see that?
He came out of the closet,
but he came out of the closet at 34.
This guy is this guy,
but look at her.
Adam's apple.
Wait a minute.
Hold up.
What's going on there?
That's a girl.
Sure.
Second.
So she just came out of the closet.
Is that what you're saying?
There's a player who plays in the NBA.
His name is Jason Collins.
He just came out this week in a sports
illustrated.
That was a big deal,
right?
Yeah.
Was he the first gay player ever?
It was the first who is actively was
still might be playing,
but he might not even make a team
because he's 34 and he's not any good.
It's like a third string center.
He might've done it because they've done
it for that.
Maybe he would go preds crude.
You're saying?
Anyway,
gay just to for publicity.
That's what you're saying.
Well,
I know he's gay.
I can see by the way,
tie that like,
look,
we're ready to put this story to bed,
but uh,
we need to see soccer cock first.
I mean,
this might be a big publicity.
You know,
you should pay a cover charge to go to
the shower.
That's funny.
That's very funny.
Bill Burr,
I don't get them.
I love people that say no,
you know,
just somebody who's jealous,
there's a lot of bills as good as any,
anything,
nothing.
You know,
there's a real disturbing thing in
comedy where people don't want other
people to be good as well.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is,
but we all know a certain number of
people who have been afflicted by that
voluntarily or involuntarily.
Some of them tried to kick it.
Yeah.
Well Jimmy Brogan's,
one of those old bitter guys and Nice
Guy,
but he used to write for the tonight
show,
you know who he is,
and he was upstairs and somebody was on
stage.
A young comic.
He was like,
listen.
And like I don't get it.
I go,
you know what?
It doesn't matter if they get it,
listen to the audience,
they get it.
It doesn't mean everything's quality,
but give them credit,
you know?
Yeah,
that's a weakness man.
It's like the why,
why,
you know,
either like it it
or don't like it,
but you know,
to really like focus all your negative
energy like that,
those people,
they become,
it's a horrible aspect to dealing with,
uh,
with other people.
It's like when you're all in the same
sort of business together and that
becomes a guy who just for one reason or
another just can't seem to get it
together.
And so they start spewing venom and then
you're around them.
You pick that up.
Like if you happen to be working with a
guy,
you know,
and he's like,
he's just bitter and nasty,
like you can ruin your whole weekend
depth.
David played in the invincible.
He played a character like that was part
of the events Nepalis group,
the guy who was the football player who
they based the movie on.
And it was really interesting character
because he was so resentful of his
friend success that when everybody was
cheering,
you just see him looking in his glass
and stern,
you know,
like fuck,
he got something else in life and here I
am at the bar,
you know what I mean?
But at that played it really well.
But it was an interesting cat because I
thought about,
I've seen it with comedians when a
comedian get something,
it's like when I,
when I started out,
I started out with Eddie Murphy,
right,
right.
And I was presenting it live and I was
like,
I was hired for three episodes and I've
ever told you that.
Yeah.
Uh,
anyway,
Eddie became a star and people would
actually say to me,
does that bother you?
That I could.
Now,
do you think that if I,
if Eddie Murphy didn't do 48 hours,
I would have nothing to do with me.
It's him.
He did it.
He's talented.
But what is it that stops people from
ever seeing that?
What is it that makes people just go,
fuck,
you fucking knew Murphy.
No frozen the movie beavin better to
what?
Fucking petty,
petty and follow me in Cleveland.
I fucking Burrito.
He was the middle of,
I was the middle,
he was the headline.
I was like,
seriously?
We know so many of them and those
stories are so gross.
The I blew him off the stage stall.
Yeah.
And crushed.
Unless they're talking about a decade
and then suddenly they become cool guy.
Yeah.
And you're like,
oh,
how bad did he eat it?
Uh,
I,
you know,
I don't like that guy plates.
I'll show,
you know,
I don't like Bobby Collins.
Right?
Yes.
And then I like,
there's only three guys I really don't
like in comedy and he's one of them.
And uh,
I,
I did this benefit,
it's called rags to riches in Vegas.
It's all these rich Jews in the Tang
garment guys.
Fucking hilarious crowd.
They're all,
you know,
like they'll think they're funny.
They're fucking.
And Bobby Collins was there last year,
right?
And I said that.
I said,
no matter how bad I do,
I know I'm not going to be worse than
fucking Bobby Collins.
Right.
And they fucking cheered because he had
a tough set.
This isn't on the air.
I know on the Internet.
It only reaches a whole world of people.
So it's a weird group.
I love that.
Um,
that they listened to the in Ireland.
Like I told you,
I'm gonna be in Kilkenny in three weeks.
Yeah.
Well that's one of the most beautiful
things about the internet as he can get
shit from anywhere.
You can listen to a podcast like London
real.
Those guys do one from London.
You can listen to a podcast from
Switzerland or Iceland or fucking
fucking cool.
Take it so much power away from the man
when you think about it.
Think about like was my main man.
You killed him.
Yeah,
it definitely does.
And every comic has a podcast now.
It's like,
yeah,
there's every comedian that I know has a
podcast that funny to me using.
Yeah.
It's like having a podcast is like
having a twitter account.
It's like having an act.
You can have an act,
but it doesn't mean it's going to be
that good.
No,
but that's true.
But it also would like,
it Kinda,
it's like it's another part of your act
sort of,
you know,
Jamie and I were talking about that
before,
before you came in and I asked him,
it was kinda awkward,
but I had to ask them,
Hey,
do you have eye makeup on?
It's just a beautiful man.
It's eyes.
Nothing,
nothing.
Not that I was like restaurant on them.
I'm just saying like glance by,
uh,
his eyes look like he had makeup on.
It's just beautiful.
It was beautiful.
The um,
the idea that you're,
you're,
um,
podcast is a part of your act.
I mean it's like,
it's uh,
when you're doing stand up,
you know,
one thing that you're selling almost
more than anything.
It's like a point of view.
It's like one of the beautiful things
about watching the guys that you get
your lock into the waste thinking and
he'd go,
oh,
I see what he's,
you know.
And then he started laughing.
But you're,
you're,
you're locked into a point of view.
You know,
you figured out a way to lock into his
point of view.
Well,
it's cool to do something without your
act,
you know,
people get like,
uh,
I told you not to struggle,
but you were,
you were because of the power of your
podcast and your popularity,
you were by far the biggest act we've
had on as far as numbers went.
Wow,
that's awesome.
We've had a lot of good guys dot Merera
live from the laugh factory podcast
Jamie was on today were really good.
You're so well.
The thing about you is,
hey,
we'll just give you each a little
massage.
She always will and celebrate each
other.
You just,
uh,
you know,
you're the real deal.
So you don't bullshit things.
You don't fake things.
It's really dumb.
I rarely they're talking.
Some people for whatever reason,
can't do that.
They get weirded out if they're doing an
interview or they,
they,
they have that hard time.
Just completely be in themselves.
But you don't know.
You don't have a punchline every fucking
sentence.
Well,
you know that,
but there's a lot of guys who don't,
you know,
they get nervous.
You thing I love about you,
dom,
is that you stayed,
you always stayed true to stand up.
Stand up is always the big thing for
you.
No matter what you did.
Like he would occasionally do a TV show
or you know,
you'd like,
it'd be great if I got a series,
but you know,
I'm a stand up comic.
That's what I do.
And you've always loved it and you're
always writing new shit.
You're always improving.
I still love you still love it.
And you still come up with new shit all
the time too.
That's like so important.
It's so,
it's such a,
um,
it's like a,
it's a rare little sort of group of,
of,
of people that we know that like really,
really love and appreciate the artist's
stand up.
Does fuck does.
Fuck already does.
It does.
Yeah.
I went on after Brian the other night at
the laugh factory.
Hey,
terrific sense.
I'm busting busting the crowd and say
some nice to follow Brian because he
sets the bar so low or whatever.
You know,
he starts hollering and made from
upstairs.
They know we're fucking friends.
I wouldn't do it like,
you know,
like when I host a show,
I said the true sign,
I don't like a person so if I give them
a straight nice intro,
if I'm being nice,
just give it.
That means I don't like,
I don't have time for.
And what people don't understand too
well if we bust each other's balls and
it's really like a pleasure.
It's fun.
Yeah.
Like if you say some stupid shit about
me,
if I say some stupid shit about you,
we enjoy it.
Of course.
Like we make each other laugh and some
people don't see that.
Like they see like two comics busting
his balls and they think like oh they
are asserting dominance and hurting each
other.
No,
they're having fun.
And the fact that they can do it to each
other,
you know,
and it's part of being a comic.
The busting balls thing is a part of
being a competent.
Well when you said something a couple
minutes ago about the guys who seriously
talk about themselves in comedy,
like,
you know what I mean?
First of all,
I'm not bragging,
but I was incredible.
I read them,
he couldn't follow up anytime.
They should have a music act when they
have to make,
just to comedy.
The lydian stand.
There was a guy that he shoved,
her name may remain nameless,
who already had a website.
We were on a podcast or a website and in
his website Id,
uh,
it had a whole shopping college about
how we blue dice off the stage following
who would that be?
Oh,
I don't know,
but the fucking silly is shit I've ever
read.
I was like,
okay,
what are you talking about?
Like one of the things I like about the
ice,
there's nothing phases him Wednesday,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He did that special he,
he aired that,
that two CD special called the day the
laughter died and he went up,
essentially went up or danger fields in
New York unannounced.
No one knew he was going there.
And if you've ever been to Dangerfield,
danger fields.
When I was a kid,
when I first came to New York,
I fell in love with danger fields.
That was my spot in New York City.
It was the nightclub was an all time
nightclub.
It was off the beaten track.
They give you a half an hour.
The crowds were very small except like
weekends and like sometimes like prom
shows were like pack there,
but you,
it was,
it was where they filmed the Rodney
Dangerfield,
hbo special.
To me that was,
it was,
it was Mecca in New York.
You know how I went there all the time,
but you,
you had to work with some really fucking
crazy people.
Who is this Scottish guy who was the
bouncer owner,
whatever.
Jimmy,
he was a character.
He looked like he was sitting down and
we understand that he was so squad.
He was a brick house falling ball.
He was a brick house.
That guy was gigantic.
Don't get a fucking left for folk sick.
He was a power lifter.
That dude,
he would like grab people and throw them
out.
There was a gentleman until someone
wasn't a gentleman time,
you fucked up.
Like he noticed he was a big guy,
but he was like deceptively straw,
right?
He would do crazy weight lifting things.
He had,
um,
like cement buckets,
buckets,
yeah.
Yeah.
He had them filled with cement and he
would do exercises with them.
He did power lifting,
did a lot of crazy shit.
That guy was stupid strong,
but he was perfect for the nightclub and
he was hilarious too.
He was always going to try again,
would that shite activists balls,
but it was warm,
you know,
and it's like he would do it with like a
half a smile on his face and he's like,
hey man,
I'm just trying to do my thing.
And he would laugh.
He was a good dude,
but if you ever got in a tussle with
that guy,
oh my God,
he was terrified.
He,
I saw him pick a guy up by his neck.
He grabbed the gun but in the back of
the neck and just hoisted him up in the
air,
but he's essentially doing it completely
by his neck to his prom shows.
Kids would come in and they would get so
fucked up.
Oh yeah.
They were so fucked up.
Do you remember Al Lubell?
Yeah.
A kid went on stage,
took the microphone away from Alabama
and blue cigar smoke in his face.
Wow.
It was crazy what I'll do.
He didn't know what to do.
I didn't want to get into physical
confrontation with him and I was a
lawyer.
I've ever.
Yeah.
So he,
he,
he backed away and you know,
I don't remember what the,
I don't remember how it was resolved
because this was Jesus.
This was like 1991 or something like
that and then empty to anybody they ever
come on stage with you?
No,
no.
You know,
I don't.
It wasn't his fault,
it was just a kid who was like really
fucked up.
The kid was really big.
It was a big football player looking kid
who's just a really bold.
They were all trying to be superstars.
This was like were at danger fields and
it was clear that no one really had the
run of the place.
It was almost impossible to,
to corral the crowds.
Oh yeah.
That's really crazy.
That prom crowd is also.
So there's one,
it's the St Patrick's Day.
It's one day everybody gets fucked up
and they were tough.
He was the crazy shows I ever worked in
my life without a doubt,
because first of all,
you would work from like the time it was
dark out from like 7:00,
he would do shelf till 2:00
in the morning and then we get off stage
two in the morning and people told me
that I didn't believe him,
but it was like it was good money.
Less spot at the Improv used to be 3:45,
3:45
in a weekend nights.
I remember having 3:30
spots.
Wow.
That is incredible.
But you know,
I don't know if I've ever told you this.
The first time I did stand up for money
was $50 at Seton Hall.
Right now I'm just fresh out of Improv,
Improv group,
all this shit.
And I go up on stage and it girl starts
heckling me.
She was fucking out of her mind.
So I bring her up thinking right.
The worst thing I could've done.
Then she's laughing hysterically and
then she starts crying.
Hysterical.
Oh my God.
Like sobbing,
crying.
And I'm thinking,
man,
it's fucking standup is harder than it
looks,
you know,
and I don't know what to do.
And then this guy,
you wouldn't know this guy,
he died a long time ago.
Uh,
he comes up on stage.
He was like,
he was a real pro and he just took her
off,
took an and found out later that her
brother's girlfriend was killed in an
accident.
So she was fucked up on pills and stuff.
And it was the first time I ever did
standup and he covered for me.
He did.
He made extra 20 minutes and all.
But I,
you know,
like this my first fucking
indoctrination.
That is whole new life.
I'm going,
Holy Shit.
Is that harder than it looks?
Shit.
Roll the dice.
Never brought anybody up after that.
That's fine.
Uh,
it's funny on Hart,
standup really is.
But then once you get good at it,
how easy it is.
Well,
it's easy because you can take your time
and you can think like,
you can literally think when you're
doing an act,
there's wrote,
it's not,
you know,
then you're thinking,
Oh,
if I lose my place,
I don't have a place so I can't lose my
place because it doesn't matter.
You don't care if you go off and
something.
I,
you know,
you gotta you gotTa always have things
to talk about.
Yeah.
But I don't know if you don't have like,
you know,
you don't do the exact same act or not
even close and that makes it so much
easier because then you know,
you're a freak and that's when,
that's when I think it gets easy.
Yeah.
That is when it gets easier.
That's why I hate doing the tonight show
and shit like that.
When they have it scripted of what
you're going to say.
It takes all the fun and spontaneity
away from what's really unfortunate that
that's still the thing,
those little seven minute conversations.
Hardest thing I do.
Yeah.
Especially because you,
you're doing it with a stranger,
you know,
even if they're,
I mean,
who's the closest to who you're friends
with at all those guys.
Craig Ferguson.
You mean calling in?
Do you do Conan?
No,
I do Craig and failing.
So like even though you see those guys,
like,
you know,
maybe every now and again I really liked
buddies with them.
It's not like no.
Sit Down with them and be yourself.
No,
but I gotta say the thing about
Ferguson,
he never gets to a question and all the
times I've done,
I've done a show probably eight times,
never gets.
They asked the head of the preinterview
and the producers called the segment
producers and they're so worried about
what you're gonna say.
Oh,
he doesn't know much about baseball but
he knows about the football and.
Alright,
alright.
And then never gets to a fucking thing.
Wow.
I had one of my most fun moments ever on
television on his show because he asked
me,
he plugged the date,
my denver comedy works and I had already
done it.
I said,
well you've got to really crack staff
here.
I said,
I've gotten so hot they have to post,
plug my dates because there'd be a riot
if they all knew I was there.
Right.
And he goes,
and then he says to me from his desk,
look,
we'll start over.
I go and starting over and he walks
over.
I go,
look,
I got a spot at the lift factory.
I got to get to.
I said,
I'm,
I'll do.
I said,
I'll do my little monkey dance for you
and I'll come over and talk to you,
but I ain't starting over.
And we had like a fake fight,
but it was great because the audience
knew it was real,
you know what I mean?
And then I went over to the panel and we
just fucked around.
That's great.
Well,
he's a funny guy and he's a.
He apparently does a lot of standup too,
right?
There's a lot of standup.
Does a lot of road gigs.
I know there's been places that I've
been where I just said he was just
there.
It was going there.
Yeah.
Good for him,
man.
It's just,
uh,
I would,
I would like to see him even more and
uncensored format for hours,
you know,
descending guy.
I've only worked with him once.
He in Toronto,
you know,
when I really became a fan of hands.
Um,
when he was talking about pretty spirits
to remember that.
No,
what did he say it was,
I don't want to paraphrase,
but it was right around the time when
she kept running into all these problems
and it was obviously something wrong.
The truth is fucking tailspin.
And He,
um,
he,
he basically was like,
why does everybody care about this?
Like you're talking about a little girl
who needs help,
like a young girl who needs help.
And it was,
it was of,
I mean said little girl,
well,
young lady who needs help.
And it was really kind of,
um,
it was refreshing.
It was like he was,
this isn't,
you could tell wasn't something that was
like he was posturing and he was making
an attempt at saying this because he
just wanted to achieve some moral high
ground.
It was a real like,
like it felt like he has a voice,
he's on television,
let's see if I can just get this message
out,
and it was so right.
It was because it was like,
why is everybody freaking out about this
young lady who obviously does have
problems when we're in the middle of
fucking two different wars and who knows
what else is going on in the world?
Who knows what the fuck else is going
on?
It was like little Lindsay Lohan.
Now it's like she makes the news,
but it's so,
so weird with that man.
It's so weird to fix it.
Like to somebody that will knock them
down.
It's so weird to fixate on individuals
like that.
It's so weird that.
Yeah,
we'd definitely like to build them up
and knock them down.
There's no doubt about that,
but it's weird how people just get
locked into that.
Yeah.
You know,
what's Lindsay Lohan up to now?
It's like once she becomes like this
side show,
they just.
There's a market.
It she,
because it's almost like she becomes
infected with fame then that fame but
fucking sucks onto her and she needs it
sorted to give her money and they need
her and people like her to fuel the
there,
you know,
the little publicity machine.
It's fascinating stuff
because they also have an incestuous
relationship.
A lot of times some of these
celebrities,
they actually choose to get their photos
taken,
the sure they asked to set things.
Oh.
And their publicists set things up with
to keep them in the,
in the chatter we have.
Fascinating.
We had Justin Bieber at the laugh
factory one night and I knew he was up
there and you know,
he even said a couple of things to me.
I was hosting a really cute little chick
that he goes out with her,
forget she's a singer.
I think it's Selena Gomez.
Beautiful.
I'm sad.
I know that,
but I do beautiful.
But anyway,
he,
uh,
his,
his manager came up to Jamie to ask me
to mention that he was there.
I thought that was so unusual because
you know,
a lot of times like say Sean Penn comes
in,
it just wears a baseball cap down.
Nothing,
not a word,
you know,
and his kid one,
the detention.
I'm thinking,
how much fucking attention do you need?
Like one of the most famous famous 16
year olds ever.
Ever,
you know.
Well that's,
you know,
he wanted it to be brought up,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like I get a hand for him really well.
He's probably,
you know,
it's this thing gets a kick out of doing
that.
You can just show up places and people
cheer him.
I bet he could like do that.
Just show up at a restaurant.
Gentleman Justin Bieber's here.
That's a fascinating thing man.
It's fascinating to me that people camp
movie stars and didn't give a fuck about
the guy who's laying in the alley start,
you know.
It's like,
well he seems like he's handling it way
better than most people would.
Well,
it's pretty unusual.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's like,
yeah,
he says some silly things every now and
again,
but he's like 17 years old or 18 years
old,
whatever it is.
You should see the girls,
young girls fucking her.
You can't say that.
I think she's too young.
She's 18.
She sent.
I think you got to lie to yourself.
What a girl.
17,
17.
You know what I mean?
And it's so key to sing back then.
Don't forget he was only 20.
I semans Christine's 16.
Remember that?
I was kiss those gene semans was just
17.
Know what I mean?
The way she looked beyond compare.
Well,
but this was a gene simmons was saying
how he has to have to have you.
That's a great fucking song.
And if you say it's not a great song,
I was like fuck you pitch.
So that's good.
That's a mature.
That's how I handle it.
Fuck you bitch.
You can't shit on my childhood.
And there was,
there were a couple of sweet 16 songs.
Yeah,
there was a lot of creepy dudes back
then.
They got away with ap with 18 people
died younger back then.
That's what it was talking about,
the Roman Empire.
Joe,
what it was five,
four,
zero people died earlier back then.
It's a known fact that what people could
have said before,
not before.
Yeah.
Before Google.
That's a big point right there.
A known
fact and like I can just bullshit you
and there's nothing you could say if he
was good at bullshit and he'd be like,
all right,
you just don't want to fucking admit the
encyclopedia Britannica.
I read all the volumes.
You don't know if you've read it.
I fuck.
We're in a quagmire here.
I can't get out of this bullshit
conversation,
asshole,
asshole.
Just bullshitting.
I know he's bullshitting.
And then you find out years later that
he was bullshitting fact.
That's funny.
Those motherfuckers,
those.
It's a known fact guys that talks about
crazy shit.
Look it up.
I can't look it up yet.
Imagined blend.
If you were like a long time bullshit
her.
Like if you.
You're a crazy con man type dude and you
just saw just an excellent bullshitter
for many,
many years.
What?
How pissed those people were when Google
came along?
Oh,
I know.
Like all the sudden,
you know,
like if they could make up a name of a
company,
make up the name of a corporation,
now you'd go,
do you have a website?
And they'd be like,
no,
we don't have a website.
You'd be like,
Oh really?
I was watching catch me if you can the
other day where Leonardo Dicaprio is
just like he becomes a pilot when he's
79 checks and getting money.
You can't do that shit today.
So I walked into a bank and they with a
pilot.
Did he perform an operation too or is
that the one?
Maybe,
I don't know.
Yeah,
the,
the idea that you could like have a fake
company and get people to invest in your
fake company and then you get that,
oh,
where's that money shit that those days
are.
You mean you have to be really dumb.
I'm sure there's people that are really
dumb or get,
you know,
the Super Gullible,
older folks are living with mental
illnesses to get sucked into a weird
deals and people that are trying to get
a quick buck.
Like the made off thing made up thing.
I was personally affected by that
because people I love,
but a lot of people were just looking
for people that you love lost money.
It's millions.
Millions.
Wow.
When you love a lot of people that are
fucking powerfully rich.
I know some people jumping around a lot
of money around a million.
Yeah.
The Bernie madoff thing was,
to me,
you know what that showed that showed
that this is a crazy system because if
you guys didn't know he was cheating,
how is it possible?
How is it possible?
Because I know where Ms Scheme and there
are people still collecting money,
so they were.
They were teased but constantly.
Well,
they weren't just teased.
They benefited and profited immensely.
Some of them made big profits,
but there's other ones that lost so much
fucking.
Oh yeah,
that guy just went baller on.
Everybody just had everybody's money.
I'll tuck that away and just squirreled
it off.
Crazy fucking sociopathic asshole.
And it's just.
What are they trying to say?
I was handed a bad guy.
He's just a victim of circumstance.
Probably a psychopath,
but the idea that it's possible for God
to do that,
that was so disheartening for me because
I thought that it was more complicated
and I thought it was more secure than
that I saw that had to do with degree to
the people to,
of wanting to be quick,
quickly rich or you know,
and these are people that,
like I said,
that the guy,
I know a lot of people that I care about
them,
but they readily admit they were looking
for a quick buck.
Right,
of course.
Yeah.
Well that's what he was promising.
Right.
And he's promising big returns to a lot
of people.
Right.
It's just a shocking thing.
Equity,
how much money he was handling,
you know?
It's really shocking.
Yeah.
And then the wife's trying squirrel
something away and disappear into the
night,
or the husband's locked up in jail for
the rest of his life.
Did one of his sons commit suicide?
I think so.
Oh,
Jesus Christ it tough shit.
You shouldn't just changed his name.
Oh my God.
Should have just changed his name.
His son made of A.
I don't think it was even that,
that sun just realized like,
no,
I think
especially when you're a young man and
you know,
probably grow up thinking that your
family is doing really well because your
father is a hardworking,
smart man and then he brings you into
the business and then somewhere along
the line they probably had figured out
somewhere along the line if they didn't
know from the jump and then the guy
couldn't take it,
I guess.
Or who knows the pressure pressure.
Yeah.
He talked about like billions,
billions and billions of dollars.
Right?
What was the number was?
It was definitely in the billions that
I've heard.
I think it was a known fact.
Joe.
Jesus Christ.
It's a known fact,
so no fact.
This fucking guy lost more money.
I'm smelling bit ski.
There's a,
there will tell you what Eddie Murphy
was.
Eddie Griffin was saying after nine
slash 11,
but a lot of people don't even know that
they still are gold under the World
Trade Center and the subways kept
running 24 hours a day.
Oh,
well,
you know,
he would get high and just crazy shit.
He,
uh,
he actually thinks he's like a genius
and I heard him one night at the store
and then who's going to argue with this
bit?
He goes,
we got to stop giving our kids and
compton guns and knives and educated
like,
first of all,
who gives the kids a gun?
He come here,
Jay,
Johnny,
I want you to have a gun and a knife
here.
Go,
go to school.
And he said,
we've got to start educating them,
given pencils and papers and books like,
who the fuck is not going to agree to
educate kids?
I don't think they need education.
They need guns and knives.
Eddie Griffin definitely had some crazy
times,
but I've seen Eddie Griffin fucking
destroy.
I saw him in his prime when he did his
first comedy special.
It was short set,
I believe.
I want to say it was a half an hour,
but it might've been even less.
A lot of confidence.
God Damn,
he crushed down around.
He fucking crushed.
He crushed.
And it was scary talent.
It was a scary level of talent.
And energy that he put out.
And I remember watching him going,
wow,
that guy is fucking good.
I remember thinking that.
Like,
that guy's got a lot of power in his
act.
You know,
it's actually scary.
It was like boom.
It was so good.
So dynamic.
The way he moved,
you know,
the way pause expressed himself and you
know,
he had like moments like that that make
me think like a fat guy just really
dedicated himself to nothing but stand
up and really went legit and went down
the path.
He had moments if you could recapture
those moments.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think he had some mental issues to,
with the fucking busy.
It's a known fact that,
uh,
that he had a people of his ilk,
standup comedian fellows.
A lot of you mother fuckers go crazy to
know.
In fact,
Damo rare.
It's a known fact.
Have your mental illness and you'll be
in funny.
It's not a coincidence.
Dot Merera.
Okay.
It's a known fact.
You know,
Joe,
you deal with to compare.
I don't think I see these people laying
in the bushes outside waiting to fucking
stop me.
Eddie Griffin was fucking funny at one
point.
I don't know.
I haven't seen any in a long time.
I shouldn't say isn't he?
Isn't anymore.
Who knows?
Might be out there killing it,
but I don't hear about them much.
I know that he has a funny guy.
I just don't want a warm guy too.
He's very warm and goodheart who he is a
very friendly guy.
Part of his deal when he goes to a
comedy club is yes to brand new
sneakers.
You ever hear this?
Oh,
I've heard.
I've heard things like this.
I didn't know it was him.
I don't know whether they're adidas or
whatever it is.
It's a big company and he has to have a
brand new pair of white Michael Jordans
or something.
I think it's Nike.
Nike,
but a fucking hilarious.
The man that guy goes,
I couldn't fucking find them.
If you write to where,
if you have a thing where you need to
wear a brand new sneakers right as you
walk on stage and that keeps you like
super power,
that might sound ridiculous,
but if you were a young guy and you grew
up poor when you got a new pair of
sneakers,
that was like a really exciting thing.
So it could be that by not wearing the
sneakers until he goes on stage,
like he liked,
he liked a,
makes them feel like with new sneakers
on,
like it gives them a little extra power
and it sounds ridiculous,
but I remember when I was a kid getting
a new pair of sneakers was like a big
deal.
So maybe for him he like kept that
tradition Joe.
And it's easier for him if they buy it.
Why don't you buy it?
Because I want to change.
Um,
right before I go on stage,
I asked you before it came on the show.
Not to be insightful and intelligent,
not to have any compassion for people.
And there you go.
You're right.
That's a good.
I try to have as much compassion for
people as possible,
even people in the wrap,
our pool game,
Dom Irrera,
people that interrupt,
I can't believe you fucking serious here
dot Merera and I,
when we,
when we play,
like we occasionally will joke around,
but John Plays very good pool and uh,
I played pretty good pool and we have
some fun battles.
It's really fun to get excited.
First of all,
we play more than pretty good not to get
the same a b player.
Now you're consistent like a.
for a regular person.
I'm an a player,
but for a regular pool player,
I'm a b player.
I just don't have enough time.
While you're more than an a player for
regular person.
No,
no,
no.
I never fucking planning,
but it ran out nine ball like you.
It's done on a regular people.
I'm telling you.
I played a lot of pull in my life.
I am.
I beat.
You know what?
It's so funny when I'm not playing
against you because I get a chance to
shoot more.
I play better.
Oh,
tighten up.
And then you want to get back on the
table.
I can run some packages,
but I can't run packages like my friends
can.
So like I have the luxury of knowing Max
everly who's like one of the best pool
player.
Very well spar.
Every time I go to vegas and play,
he was fucking.
Keeps you in the chair and the guy just
runs down from everywhere.
He's a monster.
Max Max,
I believe world.
He won the straight pool.
A championships at the Derby city
classic this year.
One of the prestigious a pool tournament
to the world.
I don't know what he randomly be.
He runs 100 balls.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
He's a world class pro.
He's a world class problem yet.
And a sweetheart of a guy.
He's a sweetheart.
Max Out.
What a nice guy.
I miss him.
I miss it too.
Who is that?
Now we will bill your Hollywood
billiards.
What was the one before that?
We used to go to the gym right off of
Hollywood Boulevard.
Across from the cat and fiddle number.
Isn't that Hollywood billions?
Well then we went to another place on
Hollywood boulevard.
What was that quote?
We went to two places for years to play.
Second.
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
The boss.
A club.
That's the first place we went to.
That place was great.
That was great.
That was a a former athletic club and
converted into this giant pool because
they had the track upstairs.
I used to play on a Saturday tournament
there.
He said when I first moved to La,
they had a Saturday morning tournament.
Was like started at like 11:00
AM I made.
I made good friends there.
That Saturday born into the tournament.
That was when I first moved here.
That was a great place.
Remember they had the like the track
along the top event?
Yeah.
I remember we doubled one night.
We took the girls to be and she wasn't
named Jerry.
Yeah.
I only remember it because she was hot
and that said,
oh,
that's.
Well that's not sad,
but yeah,
pool was a great thing.
A date,
except if a chick beats you check
beetroots.
Very depressing pool,
but there's a thing about a girl beaten
yet pool.
That's demoralizing for some dudes.
It's funny to watch.
I had a friend who said,
will you shoot my girlfriend because she
was practicing a lot and she said to me,
I'm going to kick your ass.
Oh my goodness.
All right.
So first of all,
how she,
uh,
she broke and I ran the table rather
than.
Yeah,
it was fucking easy.
It was those pockets like this.
Oh yeah.
Right.
It's not like we play on the ball just
about fits in.
And I ran the table and I go,
Eh,
so much for kicking my ass.
She goes,
we're gonna.
Play again.
And Go,
no.
Oh,
fucking it down.
Saying it's over.
Yeah.
I don't want that kind of attitude from
women.
I don't like kind of attitude from
anybody.
Anybody.
I don't like braggers and I'm going to
kick your fucking woman that can kick
your ass in pool.
She doesn't have to be rude about it.
Swimming and kick her ass and pools and
humiliating for men.
That's a nice woman who's very polite,
who kicks your ass and be like that
Allison Fisher woman,
you know,
she has.
Of course she would kicked my ass for
sure.
Easy.
She kicked my ass.
Trust me,
she's way better than me.
Who's the big blue is like a snicker
champion and she.
She came over from Europe and just
dominated woman's pool.
In fact,
here's the.
That's the real problem with pools,
popularity.
This woman,
Allison Fisher is probably the most
dominant sports person ever in any sport
in any game in women's gender issue and
it's not like there's only a few women
playing women's billiards.
There was a lot of really good players.
There was like,
you know,
everybody knows genetically drag because
she's a beautiful,
beautiful Asian woman,
but there's like a whole gang of like
top pros that would tour around the
country and this woman consistently beat
all of them on a regular basis.
She was like player of the year,
like who knows how many fucking years in
a row.
She won the US Open,
who knows how many years in a row or
whatnot.
It was the US Open,
whatever the W,
Pba,
whatever their version of like their
national championship.
She would win every year.
Why are men better than women?
Why?
That doesn't make much sense,
but any sense?
It's just a coordination thing.
It isn't,
it isn't immunity.
It can be overcome like women like
Allison Fisher,
she could beat a man playing pool cue,
but she.
She wouldn't be at the top pros most
likely not in him.
It's just a few issues with spatial
intelligence.
There's something to,
and this is like really theoretical
stuff.
I think something to the way the male
mind interprets three d space that it is
a,
it's beneficial for certain things and
pool might be one of them because after
the break pool doesn't really rely on
strength.
No,
and the average woman could easily a
stroke,
a ball about as hard as you need to,
you really don't ever need to hit it
really hard outside of the brake.
The brake shot,
especially in rotation games or eight
ball,
it becomes a big issue because if a guy
can really smash the rack,
he can make like sometimes you break and
you make like four balls on the brake
like that.
There's that Guy Shane van boning,
who's a fascinating character because
he's the best one of the best pool
player in America.
One of the best players in the world.
Yeah,
and he's deaf and when he plays he shuts
his hearing aid off and it's not good
because of that.
But it is an added element.
It's good because he's good.
He's.
He practices relentlessly.
The guy's like super dedicated.
He's good because of that.
But he's also got this added element.
We can shut that.
The heat on here.
Anything.
He doesn't hear anything.
So when he's in pro tournaments he goes
into this zone.
It's kind of weird.
Yeah,
it's kind of weird.
It's really fascinating because it's a
form of sensory deprivation and people
have actually decided that it,
it's a,
it helps them so much that people
started wearing like earmuffs and shit.
Got Real Strickland and I know strictly
he's amazing,
amazing player.
He puts these,
these things that like the um,
air traffic controllers were giant head
things over his head and he plays pool
with those lines.
Even it off with.
Yeah.
So the senses.
Yeah,
but he tries to recreate it.
He puts earplugs into.
So he puts earplugs in and then he puts
these gigantic fucking ear muffs over
the earplugs and then he plays.
He plays like a man possessed the.
Both of those guys,
they play scary,
pulls them at that level.
Pool is madness.
Willie Mosconi,
of course I've heard of.
I'm sure because he was the guy that was
the big deal in Philly when I read his
tray pool all time high run.
Really?
It's like 580 ball,
so I'm like,
uh,
yeah.
He ran it,
but it was on.
It's a very controversial because he ran
out on a four by eight,
wasn't a four and a half by nine trips
of a dark I.
yeah,
yeah.
Luther last smart guy.
Who,
if you ever heard that name.
Yes,
of course.
Yeah.
It was a wimpy,
straightforward.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
If there was money in pool when I was a
kid,
I would have become professional pool
player because I was enjoying it.
There's zero stricken with the earmuffs
on because I was enjoying playing pool
as much as I was enjoying doing comedy,
but I wasn't good enough to like we
talked about this.
You would never have the time because
you're too much of a career.
It believe me.
If you were on a law was a comedian,
you could,
you could turn pro,
but if you could play for hours a day,
it's so much time and so much effort and
the guys that are playing that are at
the highest levels of the game,
there's several notches better than me.
It wouldn't be like an easy thing to
even like do battle with those guys who
would take a long time when some nine
ballgames.
I will.
Thank you very much.
So that's straight pool.
A guy can sit you.
There's nothing you can do.
It's just too bad that that game doesn't
get like it's to me,
it's like a form of meditation.
It's like if I can get into the zone and
I can block everything else out and I
can move the ball exactly where I want
it to go and I know where it's going,
I know how to hit it,
I know what speed to hit it and it gets
the right spot.
This is a beautiful feeling to that.
It's a,
it's a.
it's like a a.
you're like enforcing this weird zen
state enforcing this state where you
know exactly how many rotations of
ball's gonna go for.
People don't play pool.
They're like,
should we shut the fuck up about pool
already?
Joe Rogan,
Jesus Christ them for fucking pool
podcast.
Don't even talk about mma.
Okay.
Jon Jones broke his foot.
You didn't say a word about on your
podcast will be.
I had to show you my shaky hand when
you,
uh,
yeah,
that's crazy.
I got this nerve issue.
What did you hurt?
You hurt your shoulder.
I wasn't as bad.
Uh,
I know.
I never heard anything and it's just
something in the nerve that chiropractor
told me.
He said,
you know,
if it doesn't bother you,
said it bothers my friends board in May.
Do you stretch out or all at all?
And doing fine.
Yeah.
You know,
I dance in my house.
Did I do a interpret?
Modern Jazz?
Do you do any athlete?
All little stair climber,
elliptical machine.
I didn't like where you're going to tell
you it is very good for the planet.
What do you want a piece of this right
now?
And May I come on over here,
let me see if I do I do the treadmill.
I do.
It's a shame when you can't tell if
somebody ever worked that static.
Do you do anything physically?
That's not what I meant,
but I was trying to find out what it was
and whether or not you incorporated
stretches,
especially the stretch out your
shoulders,
especially stretched on the road,
uh,
after flights and all that.
And you know,
that's good.
Yeah.
I did the,
a lot of people don't start yoga things,
lot of whatever I learned from the
videos.
That's my favorite thing to do before I
go on stage.
My favorite thing to do,
I do yoga.
Yeah,
that's my favorite thing to do.
I've tried a bunch of different things
that feel good before I go on stage.
Hard cardio is one of them.
Hard cardio makes me high.
Like when I really do like really hard
cardio before you go on stage for two
hours.
I like to do like two hours before.
Especially before,
like it was a big show.
If I want to be thinking about it,
I don't want to give you energy.
Yeah.
It.
Well it doesn't do,
it just releases some weird endorphin
with me or like if I do like a real hard
cardio session where I just feel silly.
I just saw it makes me Sillier,
relieves me.
It relieves me of like physical tension.
It just makes me sillier and I think
when I,
whenever I can go on stage and being
more of a silly mood and the Sillier I
can feel the more funny I think things
are,
which is the more funny and you'll get a
kick out of it.
Yeah.
The more funnier deliver it.
When you get a kick out of it and when
you're,
you know,
you're saying it in a way that's a,
that connects with people.
Sometimes it feels like too upset about
something.
You didn't understand why it connects
with people.
It has to be a and honest,
an honest balance for why you're pissed
off or why you're happy,
you know,
because it's got to be an island
balance.
And if sometimes you know,
that weird feeling when you watch them
on stage and they're acting pissed off
about something,
but you know,
they're not really pissed off about it.
And how that is that mit does this
airplane food.
Well it's not even that,
like someone like,
just to just fake it,
like whatever it is a fake laugh always
at the same time,
you know,
and I can name you find people that do
it.
I don't even want to get into the union.
You know,
when someone's mad for real and you know
why they're mad for real.
Like you feel it,
you know,
when someone's mad for real,
when they really are upset,
you know,
and you know when someone's faking it
and when they're faking it,
it's really weird.
Yeah.
It's so awkward,
too much of an act.
And I know a lot of us,
especially when you do it on stage,
it's like you just,
you know,
you don't.
If you don't realize that yet or you
know,
maybe you just out of sorts that night
could be.
You're out of sorts that night and you
just have a bad set.
You're not in the right groove.
I mean,
we've all had those over the years.
I love watching Joey Diaz because of the
jelly is so fucking real.
Yeah.
There's not a phony bone in his body.
That mother fucker now.
He's just so pure in that sense.
Like,
Oh yeah,
he's not trying to win anybody over.
No,
he's just trying to be funny to the
people who love Joey Diaz.
I think he just,
he realized somewhere along the line
that he was.
He's really good.
He realized he really is.
Yeah.
He realized that he realized that
himself and he didn't give a fuck
anymore and when he didn't give a fuck
anymore,
it's like that's when people really
wanted to hear more and so all the
people around him,
like if he had anyone around him that
didn't believe in him at this point,
they all really have fallen by the
wayside,
you know?
It's took it a long road for Joey to
like get recognized how funny he really
is.
Yeah.
And along the way a lot of people had a
chance to work with that guy and they
didn't believe in them.
I was telling people about Joey Diaz in
1998.
I was like,
you fucking crazy.
I'm like,
this guy makes me laugh hard all the
time.
He makes me laugh hard.
I go,
he doesn't give a fuck.
And he makes me laugh hard.
And they're like,
he's to this and he's too bad.
Then this doesn't work and that doesn't
work and if you can't be in a sitcom,
you know.
My agent called me up and he said,
you like Joey Diaz?
I go,
I love him.
He goes,
you want to work with them?
I go,
anything?
We're doing the ice house,
the end of July.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
be fun.
That's a beautiful show.
I might come and watch.
You know what I will say is that I think
it's 27,
28.
The flavor.
Remember in my,
my,
uh,
but was weird.
Mine that I can remember.
Shit.
I don't remember why I walked into a
room like I like.
I'm like a savant.
What days are those?
Friday.
Saturday.
Okay.
It's not the 27th.
I was running savant.
Savantas didn't kick in.
It could be the 20,
fourth and 25th.
Does that make sense?
It could be that what's the last week
and enjoy the last weekend is that.
And there's a 31st in the first.
That would be it.
The 31st of the one before the one
before it.
Damn.
I'm not even gonna be around.
I'm going to be in Vegas.
I want to see that.
Where you go.
What are you going to come on?
Go to UFC,
UFC gym.
Doing Atlanta this week.
The improv.
Then hilarity in Cleveland.
You ever do hilarides?
No,
I have not.
I'm looking forward to the Improv.
I think I did.
Maybe I did.
What other clubs are in Cleveland there?
An improv in Cleveland.
Cleveland.
Think I did.
That is one of the nicest clothes to
river scene.
It looks like a giant cruise ship.
It's got everything.
It's got to fucking Martini bar dancing
girls.
A sports bar theater.
I did a,
one of the clubs in Cleveland,
I think it was the Improv.
I did it with a half.
Ron and Charlie Murphy.
It's right next to a strip club.
I don't remember.
Can I go by.
There were markings.
My life.
We didn't have much time when we did
this tour.
I did this maxim comedy tour way back in
the day with Heffron and Charlie Murphy.
It was really fun at.
John was feisty.
He liked to fight.
Did he never seemed like that with me
with.
We were always very friendly.
No,
no,
not with me,
but other people.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I got along with him.
Great.
He's a great guy.
Yeah,
but I mean,
we were out a couple times.
I think he stopped drinking,
but he wanted to fucking fight.
That's crazy.
Oh yeah.
I was probably in the buffalo demon.
Uh,
but we,
uh,
we did that place and we did a different
place almost every night.
It was really crazy.
We were out for 20,
22 gigs after the exposure he got on the
uh,
yes,
after he won half run,
one last comic standing and Charlie
Murphy had just done the Chappelle show.
Nice guy,
fucking sweetheart of a guy.
And as real as they come and a great
storyteller,
man,
Charlie Murphy kill you in the green
room.
He'll tell you some stories in the green
room and just kill you.
He's a natural storyteller,
you know,
it's a fun thing.
You get to bring people with the and
stuff.
That's cool.
But that wasn't my idea.
That was something that maximum and bud
light put together.
We all just did it together and became
friends.
Once we did,
I was just,
I didn't know either one of those guys
before we did the tour.
So it was so lucky that they're both
cool as fuck because how fraud is cool
as fuck.
And so is Charlie Murphy and that's how
we met Tom Segura too.
We were at the,
um,
the,
the celebrity theatre and Phoenix and
Sigora was the opening act and look like
they would do maximum,
would hire like a local act,
like a local pro and they would do like
10 minutes or so before the,
uh,
the show would start with a half drawn
and then he would either be me or
Charlie Murphy and I'm the.
Most of the guys were good.
They were all good.
But one guy,
one guy was a deck,
one crazy guy in Boston was a douche
bag.
He was crazy drunk.
No his name.
Every drunk.
Yes I do.
Okay.
Well you said crazy and they all were
pretty good but.
But Segura just really stood out.
No kidding.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He went out there.
I mean the celebrity theater was a weird
place to because it was in the round.
Those shows are odd if you've never done
that before.
And I've done it.
He went out there and just played it.
He did.
Yeah.
And I know he was a tough fucking huge.
He's a big fella.
Not Anymore.
No.
I mean,
I mean it was big.
Like he's a big man,
but not anymore.
No doubt.
Be Thin,
but he was.
He was.
He wasn't always fat,
but he was big though.
He was when he would fight.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
And he might have a little bit of the
Yale and his sister before he slugged
you.
Those guys were animals.
Those guys like those cats.
Dad,
Gavin's,
nox and sox was a little bit later.
Kenny Rogers sin.
Those guys were savages.
They don't get nearly the credit they
deserve.
There should've been a time capsule that
really captured that moment in common
and they did.
Didn't somebody do a movie about them?
Yeah.
France Palamida did pretty good was when
standups shit out.
Very good actually mean for me.
I don't want to because it was so close
to home.
I guess it was much more impact.
I don't want to oversell it,
but I thought it was really fascinating.
If you're a fan of comedy,
I think it's brilliant.
I'll just never forget how they didn't
bury me in Boston.
Tried.
No,
no,
they did.
They really like.
You could tell that they had an
interesting relationship and Don Gavin
gave me a great intro and nobody tried
to.
They didn't want to burn if that's what
you mean.
Like they didn't think you were a dick.
They all loved.
Yeah,
that's good.
To me.
They would.
They would think some guys were dicks
though.
Yeah.
And they were green light them.
Oh yeah.
Because that was like a freight train of
comedy.
You couldn't fuck with that if they
greenlit billy crystal.
They did that to Richard Lewis.
Richard Lewis hid behind the stage for
the audience left.
There was these guys,
man,
and he was one of them that uh,
for whatever reason they believe that
generated.
Well.
I'm a little bit of billy crystal,
but more Richard Lewis.
They,
these guys generated a lot of hate.
Yeah.
At a certain certain Comedians,
like certain community.
It's like we're like this guy just
fucking funny.
He's not fucking funny.
You know,
I heard like club owners say that.
I was like,
why?
Like obviously some people like them,
like he obviously has like an audience,
right?
You gotta like it's from his movies more
than a stand up.
Oh,
I don't know about that with Richard
Lewis Lewis.
No,
no.
I thought you were talking about billy
crystal and Richard Lewis definitely
stand up,
but for whatever reason,
there's certain people that will love to
hate that guy or disrespect is comedy.
It's like everybody's got different
tastes and that's so hard for some
people who are fans of standup comedy to
realize that's why there's no best
standup,
but not always.
They know best standup.
You're crazy to look for it,
like don't even look for it.
It's just just just enjoy what you enjoy
because it's subjective.
It's not objective.
Like if there's the 100 yard dash guy
because the fastest guy wins.
You can't argue that.
I think that their guy was fast and
there's some guys that all they want to
see Gaffigan say anything African says.
There's some guys and gals that Gaffigan
fucking for whatever it is,
he hits their frequency and for other
folks it's a towel,
you know,
and whatever it is it is,
and you can't get upset that some guys I
could tell like I don't even see it.
I didn't see it relaxed.
Don't concentrate on that.
I know.
You know,
you just relax.
Don't get angry.
People love telling me that thing cooks
not funny.
It was like,
okay,
relax.
It's like you.
You don't have to think he's funny.
Apparently he made millions of dollars
because somebody thought he was funny,
so I get too much pleasure at other
people.
Sucking that is a problem.
That's a weird thing with people.
They get this weird pleasure out of
other people sucking.
I don't know what it is.
It's interesting though.
It's a,
it's a weird little side effect,
a little heater side effect.
It's jealousy.
It's a combination of a lot of things,
but it's so bad for the person who
thinks that that's what they don't
understand.
Like it's just a massive distraction,
you know?
So it just takes away so much energy
from your own life because instead of
concentrating on this other person,
you should be concentrating on your own
shit and if something bothers you,
you should find a way,
if at all possible.
And that's of course it's some egregious
offense or a crime or some,
some sort of sin against man and nature.
Find some way to turn it into a
motivating factor for you.
If you feel weak because you see some
guy like you know,
I dunno,
name your fucking book Mogul Bill Gates
on TV and he's got a billion dollars in
his underwear.
You know,
and you feel like you can't even fucking
pay my student loans are figuring out,
figure out what,
what the fuck you need to do so that you
become so successful.
You don't worry about Bill Gates anymore
if you don't have to be as successful of
a bill gates,
but become enough of a person who
figures your way through the net of
civilization to the point where you
don't have to worry when maybe for
everybody has their own gradient.
For some people it might be just making
a living is good enough,
you know,
for some people it has nothing to do
with how much money they make.
It has to do with getting their fucking
mind right.
You know,
go into either go into a shrink or doing
some yoga or going on a mushroom trip,
figure out whatever the fuck you need to
do to get your mind right because it
doesn't matter how much money you make
or it doesn't matter anything that else
is going on in your life.
If you don't have your mind right.
If you're not thinking about life,
clearly you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Make some Shitty,
stupid decisions.
So you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Be annoying to almost everybody around
you.
You're going to fuck things up left and
right.
Get it together,
bitch.
Hey talking to me.
Not that you don't know,
you know,
never are you a so you're going to this
defined sasquatch going to find.
So we talk about that.
Yes we are.
We can can't talk too much because it is
top secret,
but for my new Saifai show,
very soon in the near future,
I'm going to go searching for sasquatch
and very peculiar and particular
location that has been known for a high
volume of sasquatch sightings era.
Was there a particular forest that he
frequents perhaps is the same?
I can't say whether I've said too much
already,
but we will be camping and will be.
We will be getting our freak out in the
woods.
I don't think I'd want to go camp and
Joe.
Yeah,
maybe not.
I'll tell you when I get back whether or
not it was worth it.
What didn't you go somewhere with
Carolyn?
Yeah.
We went hunting in Montana.
Notice I said hunting with no gi.
That's because I'm a hunter.
I say it so often.
It just flows off the tongue.
He lived by my railroad.
I make my own eyebrows.
Oh,
that was a.
Did you ever see that Bo Jackson Jackson
thing,
but he makes his own arrows.
Oh,
does he really?
Yeah,
he's fucking crazy.
He's like a mad man.
Hunter and fisherman,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's a real outdoors calibrator and he's
sitting there and that's his favorite
thing in the world.
Well,
it's very fun.
You know,
the people don't want to hear that
because they don't want you going out
there killing animals.
They take call.
Wow.
You can't say it's fun.
You say that you call that fun man.
What's rewarding and beautiful and it
connects you to nature and it's very
humbling and it's also,
you know,
it's a really intense thing like making
your own,
getting your own food,
you know,
going out and hunting your own food is
very intense.
I don't,
I don't think everybody should have to
do it,
but for me it was a,
it was pretty intense.
I like five star restaurants,
like being upgraded me to these.
All these things are good as well.
Yeah.
I just,
I'm too lazy.
I don't want to like pick up a tent.
I feel you.
I feel you bro.
I'm not into it all the time,
but say you like it,
but I don't like it.
No,
you just do it.
Just I just because I don't like,
it doesn't mean that you went to one
with Brian.
He must've liked it.
It was cold as fuck.
We're camping out in the middle of the
snow in Montana in the middle of
freezing weather.
It didn't snow.
It did rain one day though.
You know,
it's miserable.
But uh,
I wanted to experience it,
you know,
I thought it'd be,
I think we're so far removed from being
in the wilderness that to have an
opportunity,
especially with like expert outdoorsman
to go out into the wilderness for five
days and be like,
I'm going,
you know,
this is going to be wildness.
Ari Shaffir Niagen and salmon fishing.
We're headed up to the great white north
of Alaska.
Was trying to get a date in anchorage.
Yeah.
To go salmon fishing.
You get a date in Anchorage?
Yeah.
We're gonna go,
uh,
hopefully,
go catch them.
Fucking salmon time.
I pull those women's sector giant
monsters.
Crazy fucking fish.
Fish.
She doesn't have a quickie or,
and how hard it must've been to eat fish
back before people figured out rods and
reels and spears.
Chili fucking hard to get a fish meal.
What do you get a deal?
You gotta grab it with your hand.
Stupid.
Well,
the idea,
the them swimming upstream,
there was so many of them.
You could like bad amount of the air.
So ridiculous that that was the choice
for survival,
that they would go all the way upstream
back to the river or back up the mouth
of the river at the brightest fish.
Well,
that's nuts that they live in fresh
water and and they also live in
saltwater.
What a crazy animal.
Brackish water.
Wild fucking animal.
Is that a real thing that's been going
around this thing with human like teeth?
It's called a sheep shed sheet.
She said fish.
Sheep said fish.
Yeah.
It's all over the Internet.
Fisher.
Weird band.
They're out.
They're pretty thin water and shit.
Swimming around.
I watched the show today about a
paddlefish.
Paddlefish is.
It doesn't have any bones.
Some weird prehistoric fish that lives
in.
I think there was the ozarks or
something like that.
I forget what they were saying that you
can't even catch them with like bait.
The way you catch them is by having a
line with a bunch of hooks on it and you
just drop it down and keep pulling it
up,
but keep pulling up,
trying to snag something and that's it.
If you snag it and if you snag it then
you just pull it up to the surface but
you never like legitimately catch
whenever you just got to snag one.
I never heard.
It's still a way to catch them.
Yeah,
they're enormous and they have no bones.
They're so weird.
There are some sort of weird prehistoric
fish and the way they got them,
it's so strange.
They make an incision and then they pull
out the spinal cord.
They eat them.
Yeah.
They eat everything.
They in this row of of these animals is
apparently very much likes sturgeon row,
which is what caviar is,
which is worth a lot of money and so in
order to make sure that they didn't
allow a market for this stuff to
develop,
even though it's legal to kill the
animal and legal to eat the animal,
it's only legal to possess it's row on
the dock.
You could only either have it on your
boat or on the dock,
so you got to either eat that row or
throw it out because you can't take it
with you because you can develop a
market for it.
You can't develop a market for it
because then the animals road would be
worth too much and they would worry that
even though you,
you know,
you have a certain number that you can
kill and a day and eat.
Like they say it tastes good.
They say it tastes like pork as they're
saying.
When they.
They grilled it,
they said it because like a lot of
people have an aversion to eating it
because it's a strange.
Like.
It's almost like they have prejudices
against it because it doesn't have any
bones and it looks like it's a fucking
billion years old.
It looks like a crazy dime.
Swordfish.
It's missing the keep discovering new
species.
The.
Have you ever heard of the snakehead
fish?
Yeah.
Those are a real problem.
They have snakehead fishes in fishes.
Is central snakehead fish have been
spotted in central park central park.
Yeah.
Thanks for finishing my sentence.
This they've invaded in central park at
a fuck.
They get there.
Somebody had to bring them.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's what's going on in have water for
a couple of days.
Which is the scary part.
They walk.
Do they walk the walk?
Did you ever see that?
A special about the Congo where I think
that's where they live.
I think where they live isn't the Congo.
Um,
it's the then into Asia and Russia is
what this says.
Is that what it is?
What this article says?
They're probably right.
I mean,
I'm sure I'm wrong,
but there's a fish like it.
It might not be the snakehead,
but this is.
There's a video.
Let me see if I can pull it up on
youtube.
It's a BBC Congo,
and uh,
I've talked about it before.
It's really a damn shame that this video
isn't like one of those,
um,
you know,
those mother earth or a planet earth DVD
setups,
whether they're super easy to get
everybody knows about them.
Right?
That's like,
if you want to see some cool shit on
nature of the planet Earth series is,
is amazing.
Well,
the BBC One,
the Congo one really should be just as
fascinating to people.
It's really sad that a,
that for whatever reason that that video
is hard to get ahold of.
But in one of the scenes there's this
weird fish probably similar to snake
head gets out of water and start to walk
in and you're like,
I can't believe this.
It's his walks over to another puddle.
Then jumps in you like,
you literally can't believe what I'm
seeing it.
Like this is a dinosaur is fucking
thing.
Just did some dinosaur shit.
Wow.
I mean,
we're literally seeing life evolve.
That's what I mean.
That's like the beginning of that,
right?
The ability to come out of the water and
walk on the ground to better water.
Holy Shit.
What a freak.
You fucking snake fish thing,
whatever it is.
And they call it a snake fish.
Oh No.
I wonder what it's called in the Congo
snake.
Snakehead fish.
Um,
the Congo is apparently like one of the
densest,
densest rain forests in the world.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck that,
that fish.
It's called naked something else.
But um,
if you get a chance to get ahold of that
documentary,
I think it's just called BBC Congo.
Let me Google it real quick.
I think that's what it was called.
There's something coming up for mystery
fish of the Congo,
but the video won't play.
Well,
there is also those ones that you've
already watched a show.
Um,
river monsters.
Yeah.
That guy is bad ass.
He's a fishing motherfucker.
That guy went out in the wooden canal.
I used to think nothing of that show.
I say,
Oh,
there's the guy fishing.
What's the big deal?
No,
this guy finishes how the locals fish.
He got an this wooden boat.
Okay.
With like a hundred hooks in it and they
were in this like tipity top one,
but,
and they're dropping these lines in for
giant catfish.
So at any point in time something could
fucking grabbed one of those lines and
hold those,
those fishing lines and who knows how
many hooks are flying in that guy's
direction.
And actually people have died from that.
Like one of the people in this tribe
died from that.
He got caught on a hook and dragged
underwater.
Like that guy is legit.
And this is the other thing that he said
while he was there,
there,
um,
one of the people are the main people in
their tribe that chief disappeared.
He was gone for a whole day and they
were seriously worried and because they
believe in bad spirits and bad omens,
they believe that he had caused the
chief to disappear.
And if the chief didn't come back,
they were planning on killing him.
They were going to stone him to death.
But thankfully the chief came back and
everybody was elated because like,
but he was like,
you don't understand how close I came to
dying.
Like they would have tried to kill him
because they felt like he was a bad omen
and he created,
even if you didn't actively do anything
to the chief,
he created the bad luck that made the
chief disappear is fucking canoe,
motherfucker.
What's that joke?
It was a stupid joke.
But a guy,
uh,
is captured by these savages and they're
going to eat him.
Right?
And he said that,
I'm going to butcher the joke,
but I just loved the punchline.
And he goes,
well,
what are you going to do with your skin?
They go,
we're going to make a cannula out of it.
And it grabs a knife.
He goes,
yeah,
you're fucking canoe.
That's harsh joke.
That's a tough joke.
That's a tough job.
A from a tough neighborhood.
Joe,
Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania.
It's a non factor.
Did 90 percent of all queries come from
your town to have the best one is only
two types of things and come from
Oklahoma steers and queers.
Somebody was the first guy to say that,
believe it's some mothers anymore.
Guys still live there?
Yeah.
Still live.
There ain't no.
Well you can't.
You can't call him fag and no more.
What else?
Thought and revolution.
Queer seems to roll off the tongue
easier.
He's sending like the main Larry the
cable guy to the meeting.
Larry the cable guy.
Larry tights am telling you to suck my
dick real quick.
Here's how bad my taste is.
There's a better manager or agent.
I would be Dan witness's name,
right?
Great Guy.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
I've met homeboy.
I was trying to talk him out of the
Larry the cable guy was that was
basically trying to talk about it,
but the life of a billion dollars.
I sit down.
I love this character is strong,
but you know,
you're like your old character better.
Uh,
I dunno diamonds still pretty well,
but it'd be you fucking wrong.
Will you fucking wrong.
You have to say it twice for rarer bad
advice.
Stama river coming down on me.
Joe.
He the wolf has then a guy.
Has a guy ever become like really good
that you didn't see coming.
We saw them in the beginning and Whoa,
this guy's fucked because we know.
I'll tell you who these killing really
good.
That was that I
was more surprised because he was so
shy.
And Brian Reagan.
Oh,
Brian Regan's.
Every fund.
Yeah,
but see Brian,
I knew him since the beginning.
He was like 19 year old kid,
20 year old.
That was an MC and he was just gracious
and deferring and not silly at all.
It was like a steam.
It's like a classic,
like tonight show stand up.
But none of the,
you know,
the,
the ghoulies like all over the place and
the character,
you know,
he's fucking brilliantly funny.
He just knows how to be funny.
It's his style to his,
like his style of being funny.
So he's got his own.
Brian Regan.
Yeah.
He's like one of the,
just like a few guys,
like maybe three or four guys that are
like squeaky clean,
but that everybody agrees are awesome.
It used to be Hedberg,
Hedberg dot.
Everybody loved Hedberg.
But what people forget is if Hedberg was
squeaky clean.
Really?
I loved that.
Brilliant.
It was brilliant.
He was a really an all time great for
me.
He's one of the few guys that I was to
this day.
I'm like,
listen to his old stuff just to laugh if
I'm at the airport or something like
that.
I still love him.
He was on.
Remember full frontal comedy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And the Hedberg was on.
I remember one line he said,
uh,
no matter how much I practice tennis,
I'll never be as good as the wall.
The Wall is relentless.
Like he took like an old expression and
made it a really funny bit playing
tennis ball against the wall.
Like this fucking guy's playing tennis
ball against the wall.
You never go.
When he told me he turns it into like
one of the best bits ever.
Fucking brilliant.
I was just in his home.
I go,
well,
one of his towns,
Austin box gone.
He's from Minneapolis listening,
but he did a lot of comedy in Texas,
but I met him in Houston,
but they really are big fans of his down
there.
Yeah,
he was awesome,
man.
He was beautiful.
It was really great and finding great
standup.
It was really fucking funny.
What time have you offered me coke at?
At,
at a,
a party in Montreal and he's such a nice
kid,
you know,
I go and I said,
I don't do coke.
He goes,
I'm sorry.
I know.
Sorry.
Fucking generous.
It's basically go up for me a $200
sweater.
No,
it's nice.
It's.
Janice just said,
I don't happen to do it.
I'm not.
I'm not judging it.
He came up to me in Rochester,
New York we met for and he was so proud
that he was only drinking beer.
You know,
he wasn't doing drugs.
He said,
no.
I said,
so basically you're bragging to me about
only being an alcoholic kind of.
There is such a giant difference between
those drugs and all the other ones.
The opiates and those are the.
I saw a commercial the other day for a
some sort of clinic for opiate
addiction.
Just talking about,
you know,
how easy it is to get hooked and all the
different people that are hooked and
don't want to admit they're hooked and
they're showing you the examples of I
would like to it I'm serious.
I would love to do if there was,
you know,
I mean if there was,
it was so dangerous,
but I love the feeling because I don't
want fucking.
I don't want to be high.
Like I don't want to be like meth or
anything.
Speedy cocaine.
Yeah.
That's scary.
You already know.
I don't even drink too much coffee,
but fucking mellows.
I like,
I like to be nodding off,
throwing up.
It was a sense of music all of a sudden
I think already I saw.
Yeah.
You get to the root of things.
What do you like to try heroin now?
When you like to know what the feelings.
Like I don't trust myself.
I don't trust that I wouldn't like it.
Yeah.
I don't trust.
I don't trust anything.
This is my rule and I don't tell anybody
what to do ever,
but that's not true.
Why am I lying?
I'll tell you,
don't do it.
Um,
I don't fuck with anything that's
addictive.
I don't fuck with anything that can get
you.
You don't even like coffee because
coffee can get,
you know,
I take weeks off upon all the time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All the time that's fucked up.
The only time I.
I'm absolutely smoked pot.
He used to be before Jujitsu,
but before isolation tank,
I'm almost always do it before that or
before writing a lot of time to do it.
Before writing.
It helps you.
Well,
yeah.
I like to.
It gets me into a nice groove.
It helps me release my current grasp on
reality.
I just think when you get an opportunity
to look at things from like coffee
doesn't do that.
Coffee sort of inspires movement
inspires me to act to me,
to have energy to start things off.
But for me the best inspiration is like
a mental inspiration because inspiration
where I could step away from it all and
see it from a different perspective.
So that's what a lot of times we're
getting high does for me allows me to
just like move over to the next window.
You know,
I've been looking at things through the
window of sober sustained reality.
Let's move over and look at things from
the.
Oh look it over here,
but if you're kinda high and you relax a
little bit,
you realize this is kind of funny.
Really.
And then he start poking holes in things
instead of.
I don't get funnier at all with alcohol.
I,
that's the only thing I ever do,
but it's one Martini will get me funny.
Yeah.
Two martinis.
Not so funny.
It's really a big difference.
I mean it's really a bit.
It really,
it just slows me down enough where I
don't feel that fucking,
you know.
And keep bottom.
Oh yeah.
Well I can do one is,
yeah,
like a little bit of a buzz,
like a tiny little bit of a buzz.
It's kind of Nice to nervous.
You get nervous at all?
No,
I get the only time I get anxious at all
is if someone I know is going to be
there.
Like maybe.
But that makes me like usually performed
better.
Yeah.
I'll,
you know,
I'll be a little bit sharper.
I'll try.
I'll be a little bit more alert,
which is everything,
right?
Comedy clubs give me a
theater sometimes 2000 peoples a lot.
For me.
It's weird.
It's a different sort of experience.
I did a trap in Atlantic city and it's
the only 2000 seater that I do that.
That has so much a meaning for me.
I've done them in Canada than.
But like my family's there.
My friends are there.
It's my home and that's a little
fucking.
That's where I get a little bit,
you know?
Yeah.
I filled in my stomach was a lot of
fucking human beings.
Stands in $2,000,
bucks a lot of materials to an hour and
10.
Yeah.
It's fun though.
Snow,
better Gig on the planet.
So fun.
I've done so many different things,
but there's nothing like the comedy.
Nothing like stand up,
nothing like that either as a,
an audience member.
Like I like a lot of things.
Obviously.
I like a different sports and like mma
and uh,
I like going to movies,
but I like going to see a really great
stand up.
I learned.
Yeah,
it's fun and laugh and be separate
yourself from it.
I did get excited is still I like when I
see someone who's really good,
I want to go right?
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Oh yeah,
a hundred percent.
I was left back to the other night and
it's funny because it was the comedy
store first and I didn't feel like I,
I canceled Friday,
never cancel.
I was just beat.
I and I sent,
Bill Burr said something that I had been
thinking.
He goes,
I just don't have anything to say
tonight.
I don't feel funny.
I don't feel like going on.
And I thought I got it builds saying it,
you know,
somebody I respect so much and I always
find that the comedy store,
but by the time I got to the laugh
factory I was juiced and ready to go and
I loved it because it was,
I'm seeing all these college students
laughing at me and you know,
it's very young crowd and there was four
slash 20 year old girls right in the
front.
I go,
when would I ever get a chance to talk
to you?
I'm like three feet away for 20 year
olds.
I said you came up to you at a bar last
pops,
you know,
before I report to the manager and it
was funny.
It's fun,
man.
I'm still driven by that,
that,
that ego with showing off in front of
pretty girls.
It's really that.
How much of a factor is that in your
factor?
It's,
I mean,
I get a kick out of it.
I get a kick out of making them laugh
and you know,
tough guys,
something fucking crack.
Like a guy who looks like a gang member,
you know,
I see him in the fucking just get the
whole gang member dodger jacket.
So just like little challenges.
Yeah,
that's part of the fun of it for sure.
I just think it's amazing when you can
translate to other groups,
you know?
I mean let's face it,
if I was fucking stuck with Gumbos my
age,
I'd be dead in the water.
You have to translate,
you have to go across generations.
My favorite is old ladies that laugh at
me in that grade is my favorite and they
see them fucking crying.
Like if you see like a girl,
like sometimes they get college could
have come over to grandmother,
see them both laughing at a joke,
you know,
the first time in her life to do,
a seed be amazed.
I mean,
especially because the old ladies today,
they'll like,
you know,
they were around in the seventies,
eighties,
you know,
and now they're in the sixties and
seventies and coming out to comedy clubs
like they have pretty God damn good
sense of humor.
Yeah,
right.
They didn't grow up in an innocent
depression.
They didn't grow up in the depression.
That's a difference between,
you know,
our parents,
parents and,
and these people that are coming up
today.
Yeah.
It's a more relaxed bunch.
I grew up with Jimi Hendrix.
Yeah,
there's,
I,
I've,
I've had a lot of like older gray haired
folks come up to me after shows and.
Great.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
So there's no reason to not just enjoy
yourself and have fun.
Like,
oh,
this is like,
we have a lot of self imposed
restrictions on the way we view things
and the looseness in which we approach
things.
And a lot of it is just because people
have to work,
you know,
they have to be serious because they
have to work all day Shitty fucking jobs
all day.
It's hard.
It's hard to.
It's hard to really have time to step
back and make fun of it all and step
back and look at it for what it really
is.
Some weird temporary state that could
end at any minute.
Yeah.
You know,
it's gotta be a weird thing to be a
person who's an old person.
It's just locked and rigid and set in
their ways and not seeing the end coming
like a God damn freight train just
rolling down the track and they're just
going to get philosophical with rogue
act and Conti fucking fucking energy in
life.
We know a lot of folks like that though.
I think it's funny the guys who won't
talk,
you know,
don't they don't talk a certain way in
front of women and yet they have no idea
that the group of women are fucking
pigs.
Talking about fucking sucking cock.
And Alicia.
Yeah.
There's some guys that are just.
There's other boys club guys.
Some guys don't want to know either.
There's some guys that don't want to
know that women,
like some guys want like really innocent
fantast choker women.
Well,
maybe they just want to find that one
girl from Wisconsin came here and hasn't
been spoiled yet.
Tom Or mary ever think about that.
Yeah,
I did.
All right.
Okay.
Don't jump down.
Don't get fresh.
Do you ever hit the whatever happened to
give me the business.
It gives me the business that ever
happened to fresh.
I think we should bring that back like
don't get fresh.
I think that is a nice thing you can say
to be.
Jamie today is running a podcast.
He was holy Christ.
Why do you let him on the podcast?
First of all,
I thought he wanted to come.
Very.
Summit was on your beautiful man,
but that's a terrible idea.
He was.
He was doing a filibuster.
I said Jamie did.
He would tell you.
He was telling the guests to shut up by.
Listen to me.
I've been running the laugh factory in
1975.
I work.
I work for the.
Hold on buddy.
He kept saying,
the pressure shut up,
I have a guest on and tell them to shut
up.
These are fucking guests.
He was brutal.
So many people.
That podcast I did with you and him,
they were like,
please don't ever bring them.
It was like the majority of the
comments.
I was like,
who the fuck is that guy and why is he
on with Joe and dom that tells you what
they said to they go,
we think you're not the majority.
I made that up.
We think you're funny,
but you got to lose the little Mexican,
the quantum,
a little Mexican boy.
Why are you blaming this on Mexicans?
He's,
he's Iranian Jewish Israel,
but what a fucking character that's
being really shitty at being racist
thinking he's Mexican and it's like,
you're racist.
You just suck at it.
You even suck at being a racist.
What do you do the fucking Mexican,
like defeat.
Even Bobby,
listen to me when I was in a small
country a long time ago.
Yeah,
that sounds exactly like a Mexican I
hear,
but they listen to me.
Listen,
I've been working laugh factory since
1976.
Every year was sooner.
He gets younger when they came over here
by dad.
Listen,
I was six years old.
I came by myself,
by the microphone.
I sneak them in my underwear,
like,
come to Medica.
Silly Bitch.
Those buddy.
Hey,
he's still kicking man.
Still supporting standup if it wasn't
for guys like him.
People that own comedy clubs,
they're all crazy,
but you have to be crazy to own a comedy
club.
He loves it.
He loves comedy and he loves the.
This,
a few people that like,
um,
they drive comedy in this country.
You know Wendy from Colorado from worse.
She drives comedy in Colorado,
but a story,
she was a waitress.
She ends up owning the club.
She's awesome.
She's a beautiful person too,
but she's drives comedy in Colorado.
Like she was one of the reasons why,
like when I wanted to escape to escape
from La,
when I was looking at a place to go,
Colorado was one of my choices and one
of the reasons being that she has like a
real comedy scene there.
It's like a legit comedy.
Says,
yeah,
she's got opened microbes all the way up
to headliners like local headliners and
she works.
Those guys like she has like a whole
like rotation and you know this,
you're allowed to do 10 minutes and here
you allow to do 15 minutes and she
develops comics.
She has open Mike Nights.
A lot of people forgot about open Mike
Nights.
Yeah,
Jamie still hasn't.
It's beautiful.
You have to have them.
Yeah,
you have to have them.
There are so important.
It's the problem is a place like la
where everybody thinks they're fucking
funny.
Yeah.
You know which everybody's socks in the
beginning,
but some people suck to the point of no
return.
You see it in soccer.
That being gay was terrible.
I didn't.
You were awesome.
No,
I wouldn't say it was awesome,
but I think I didn't suck because I was
already over my nerves because the
acting.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
I mean I didn't,
I didn't have much of an act,
but I don't think.
I think I always could bail myself out.
I don't want to sound like a jerk off
and send it in seven,
but I'm sure I would think I suck.
I don't,
I'm not the biggest fan of money today.
So I was very socially anxious before I
did stand up.
But I also was able to teach martial
arts and uh,
because I had taught so many martial
arts classes,
um,
I had like a little bit less fear of
talking about we should have had,
or at least you're doing public
speaking.
I had conducted a class.
I took many classes,
you know,
this is what I was doing for a living.
How far did you go and martial arts?
When I was 19 I was teaching taekwondo
at Boston University.
I was a black belt,
but I was a windows black I think when I
was 16 or 17,
so probably 17,
somewhere around there.
And uh,
I won the Massachusetts state
championship like four years in a while.
Yeah.
I want a couple of other.
So good for your head to get hit.
No,
I mean the emotional head.
Well,
it was for me,
for me at the time it was big,
but uh,
the teaching,
it was really satisfying watching people
learn things.
That's what I,
I learned.
I really love sharing things and I also
learned that in sharing like teaching
techniques with people,
I really concentrated on my own
techniques,
like a,
I think a lot of my kicks and a lot of
my movements got even sharper because I
was teaching them to be,
but like it was breaking them down and
showing them how to do them from scratch
and then have like a few people.
There was this one girl that I trained,
she came in as a white belt and then she
got all the way up to,
I don't want anybody to get mad at me,
but I believe it was yellow,
green,
blue,
red,
black.
I think that was a thing.
She got up to blue which was a pretty,
you know,
pretty high and I'm means you're
starting to compete against people that
are there.
Other dangerous they can kick in the
fast,
you could get crazy.
And she won this tournament and I was
coaching,
so I coached her from the time she was a
white path all the way to the till the
time she was like,
that's cool.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
And she was a young kid.
She was in high school and uh,
she was,
uh,
she was really talented.
She just knew how to listen and she knew
how to listen and she knew how to do.
Like when I,
what I explained she could like and she
was like super focused.
It was really interesting teaching
someone something and seeing something
like someone completely dive into
something that you,
you appreciate.
And watching them get better at it.
So rewarding to be able to pass that on.
I always used to remember like my
instructor,
um,
when like there was guys that were
really good in the class and they did
something really good,
you know,
whether it was a sparring demonstration
or whether they,
uh,
did a drill in the bag or something like
that.
He had his beam of joy in his eyes when
he saw you do it really well.
Like,
you know,
like when you really take it,
know he would get excited and like that,
like you could see it as like,
I didn't understand it then,
but when I started teaching I realized
like there you,
you're taking part in someone's joy by
helping them create something by helping
them create these movements and figuring
out how to do these movements correctly.
That it's not just like learning how to
kick,
it's like it's like tapping into this,
this area where you have control over
the whole package.
Even for just a brief moment and he
doing that.
Like there was a phrase that they had
from the taekwondo,
a brochure when you signed up that I
never forget.
Said that it was a vehicle for
developing your human potential.
So like that's,
that's how I thought of it and that's
how I would teach it.
So when you were teaching that you like,
it's like I had an opportunity,
I was felt like I had an opportunity to
show somebody something that can change
their life and I'll show you what
changed my life.
I'll show it to you and you can do it
too.
And it'll change your life to you.
You will literally become a different
person.
You know,
I taught fourth grade and now those kids
are grown up and that's really cool
because some of them told me it was the
best year of their lives.
They come to see me do stand up.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Very cool.
Will you teach and what grade to you
know everything but oh,
fourth grade is different than science.
Everything.
I mean,
yeah,
it's different than what you did because
you went to people who had like an
interest and a love for something.
And when did the explorer you were,
you were doing.
But mine is different.
They had to be there.
So my thing was self doubt,
self esteem.
I figured I can't teach these subjects
are going to come and go in their lives,
but teaching them self esteem and some
of the most rewarding things where like
I had this one kid who was real shy,
he was so shy.
He was real tall and he was embarrassed
by it.
And he would stay in the car and the
cloak,
cloak room,
they'd call it a,
you know,
we're all the coats and they just stay
in there.
It won't come out.
I go sky,
Sky King because he was a space cadet
goes sky,
you got to come out,
you can't stay.
I can't let a kid just sitting,
you know.
And by the end of me just like work in
his self esteem and all.
He was in the middle of the class,
just what everybody else waving his
hand.
And his mother came up to me and she was
really touched by it and told me that I
changed his life and you know,
that kind of Shit's cool.
And now I got a couple of the girls come
to see me and she goes,
one of the girls goes,
Ms Dot Turner or why did you let us do
so much stuff?
You know,
like I said,
because you were smarter than me.
I said she'd go with me.
I said,
look,
you know,
I,
I had more knowledge because I was an
adult.
But you know,
kids love of you have more brainpower to
me.
I know I wasn't dumb.
I was smart enough to know that I
wasn't.
That's why you ran the class.
Know what I mean to say you were an easy
teacher.
That's where he talks real easy.
I told them at the beginning of the
year,
I said,
look,
I want this to be the most fun year of
your life.
Only you can mess it up.
I said,
fucking awesome opportunity.
That must have been.
And I said,
I want to go to the gym.
This is one.
I was playing basketball.
I said,
I want to go to the gym more than you
do.
So the.
We were going to have a party every
Friday afternoon.
Well,
I would have.
We'd have like kids that would do break
dancing and stuff.
And Really?
Yeah,
it was.
Whoa.
That's awesome.
That was great.
Did you ever try to pitch that as a
sitcom a no,
but somebody else had an idea for a
couple times.
It would be hilarious Sitcom.
It seems like a natural.
Yeah.
You as a,
as a funny teacher because you really
did it.
It's legit and if you really stop and
think about it,
that would be like for a kid that's like
one of the greatest rolls of the dice.
A kid can get for a fourth grade teacher
at Dow.
Rarer for you.
Fourth Grade Teacher,
she still calls me Mr Herrera,
she,
she's 26 years old or 26 when I say
whatever,
and then she calls me Mr.
I rarer right and I go,
Theresa,
first of all,
you're taller than me.
She's always hot blonde.
I go stop with the Mr.
either call me dumb because I just can't
call you dumb.
That funny.
Like she's got you got me down as Mr.
that's good.
That'll keep you from being a dirty
bird.
Whoa,
whoa.
Stay away.
Dom known as since she's a little girl.
Let him talk.
Call you ms dot rush.
Trying to establish boundaries.
Somebody said,
why are you so young?
I go,
because I can come on.
Oh Geez.
That was one of my favorite bits that I
mean it wasn't even like a.
It was like almost like an interstitial.
It was fun to do it in between.
Just to kill.
Come up folks.
Give a little,
get off your high horses.
Even jokes that were killing you would
throw that ever.
Nathan Lane?
Yes.
It was like a musical,
but a bunch of them.
He's great.
He's.
He lives in New York.
It was in the producers.
I shouldn't even say cut your fall.
Anyway,
he used to give me.
Houston had a great.
His great memory and he wouldn't.
I would do that.
Fritzy Anderson character and he would
remember she goes,
get off your high horse because I would
go.
Your high horses.
Come down up here were exalted
mountains,
retreat for your fatigue.
Plateaus.
Come out folks out and it was just so
much fun to do because it was so
physical and loud and was like,
we used to kill my voice.
What do you call a dog with no legs?
Not In,
no matter what you call me.
Hey,
come in.
Where did I lose you?
Hello?
Yeah.
Having characters that you can just
bring back like that.
So it was fun.
That was a fun
character.
It was just like,
oh,
it was a conglomeration of every lounge
mountain comedian I've ever seen.
You know,
like the sappy songs.
I write the jokes to make the whole
world smile,
you know,
that kind of guy.
I had a nightmare last night,
I guess it was last night that I bombed
on stage in a hell Gig and long island.
Wow.
Very specific.
Oh God.
Because the long island was a.
I did a lot of hell gigs in Long Island.
Yeah.
You've done brokerage and governors and
did the nice places too.
But I also did fast eddies and
Huntington.
I didn't know that.
That was,
uh,
it was when I,
my manager,
I got my manager convinced to let me be
dirty because Jeff,
whichever looked at the beginning,
you picked me up and I was a scrub.
He picked me up.
I was an open mic or we'd been together
forever.
He's the best he is,
but I love him too.
He's my friend,
you know,
just a manager.
He said the best manager and I love
them.
But,
uh,
in the beginning,
you know,
we were still trying to figure it out.
I was only like 27 years old,
I didn't know shit and maybe you should
be clean like that was back in the day
where everybody should be clean,
you know.
And I'd done some clean sets,
do,
like he asked me to do what I think I,
he asked me to do one clean set for him.
So I did a clean set at like,
catch a rising star.
But then we went to um,
um,
uh,
the,
the place that was way out.
Was it east side?
Yeah,
east side comedy club went out.
I did a settle there and then we did a
set at this fast Eddie's place in this
fascinating place to live.
And there was a dude named George Gallo
and if you remember him,
he was onstage and he,
it real physical act and he was doing
this thing where he would do a reverse
shit with a banana to,
I guess he would like put the banana,
like fully formed on his lips then suck
it back into his mouth or something like
that.
And he called the reverse shit with a
banana.
And so Jeff,
I'll never forget,
he looks over at me.
He goes,
you don't have to do this,
I'm going to get you out of this.
And I go,
no,
no.
I told them,
I go,
these are my people.
trust me,
we're going to be fine here.
I know how to make these people laugh.
And so I went up and did my gig material
because I did so many hell gigs.
That's when they started being dirty
again.
What was the one he was convinced he
gave in watching that one set in this
crazy nightclub?
Like it was the end of discussion
whether it should be clean.
He goes,
okay,
we just got to concentrate on,
just go all dirty.
So he said he's the best.
Having a guy like that,
a as a manager just takes all the worry
out of like career and handling things.
You know,
like you've got a relationship like that
with God.
You love the guy like family and it's
also your manager.
It's really alleviates so much,
you know,
is the best.
So Shandra,
they're the best,
but I just got so lucky that I met them,
you know,
just like cookie faces out there and a
lot of crazy fucking people in show
business.
I mean how many looney toons managers
that we met,
how many people off the deep end,
how many people did fucking swindle
people and wound up stealing money or
owing money are embroiled in controversy
every other year.
Lenny Clarke got fucked,
fucked.
So did,
uh,
so did Jerry Seinfeld.
He got fucked around as well.
A lot of guys did.
Some agents stole hundreds of thousands
of is I.
Oh,
I'm not getting dirty sacks of shit.
It's funny business.
We're,
I'm Tamera.
You and I have known each other for a
long fucking time now.
Yes.
We put another 20 years,
20 years of nine ball to think I'd be a
little better.
A lot of fucking pool dot Barrera
concentrate on his stroke.
We still going to shoot tonight,
bitch.
Come on son.
I got two hours.
To me,
that's all.
That's all you need.
Two hours.
That's what the doctor ordered,
son gotta.
I gotta I gotTa tell you now gelatin,
relaxed.
I'm dom irrera.
Where can the folks that you next?
I'll be at the Improv and Atlanta this
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
and then the following.
I didn't even know the Atlanta the day
had an here.
This nice new.
Pretty new.
Yeah.
Wow.
I want to hear how I got the Gig.
I was doing a benefit for animals was
for Alan havey and for animal shelters.
Alan Haven.
I didn't even know what it was.
I just went in because it was allen and
I said I to maybe Alan needed money and
then they go.
No,
it's for dogs and cats.
Go Fuck dogs and cats.
I'm kidding.
You know.
But uh,
anyway,
so then I get a call the next day I'd
been wanting to go to Atlanta and uh,
but Friedman called and my agent and the
funny ball Bud Friedman's opening this
trait.
Well,
he's booking it.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's funny.
Wow.
I didn't know about book things anymore.
Yeah,
he does like Reno and Tahoe and I had
something at the Improv a couple of
years ago where he was like officially
retiring,
but he always does.
Yeah.
You know what it is is probably too fun
for them.
Has Been in the fucking business his
whole life.
He can't get off and he loves getting up
and saying hello.
He does.
Comedy is a great fucking thing.
Is still be a part of a fun thing to
still be a part of it.
Is that my cleveland the following we
got to tell you and hilarity.
Then I'll be in kilkenny.
If you're a standup comedy fan.
I don't think there's ever been more
funny guys around than now.
I don't think so either.
I think it's one of the this.
Yeah,
there's so many good people.
Men,
women.
There's so many.
There's so many funny checks.
I think it's more funny chicks now than
ever before.
Ever before.
Yeah,
I know Sarah Silverman the other night.
Man,
she fucking.
She's delirious and Schumer.
I think they rank up with the funniest
checks of all time.
I don't know.
Amy's work.
Bonnie Mcfarland does as well.
She's fucking hilarious.
She's hilarious.
She's very smart.
She's a very smart person.
She sees things.
She points out things and you,
you know,
they make sense.
You go with it.
It's hilarious.
She was.
Yeah.
You ever heard the podcast?
She gives me anxiety.
She tortures him.
That's torture.
So it hurts my feelings.
Like rich did shop to shut the fuck up.
Just pleased rich.
Well,
she's hot or smarter.
I'm just saying that.
It's funny.
That's funny.
Podcast.
The best comedy coupled by far is a
cigar and Christina Pedensky.
Christina,
you don't know her.
Thomas Girls.
Wife.
Dude,
that chick is fucking funny.
We did one of sand Tripoli shows,
you know Sam Tripoli Naughty show and
Sam Tripoli's.
Naughty shows.
He's never seen him.
He does.
He shows the Improv and they're not just
comedy.
There's like all kinds of craziness to
it.
Stars.
They would like.
They played some thing where if the guy
got the question wrong,
the porn star beating with a belt.
So this chick is like beaten this dude's
ass with the belt and everyone's
screaming and going nuts in there and
boom.
They bring Christina Palicki onstage and
I was,
she's very pretty,
but she's not like a porn star looking
chick.
She was like a very pretty regular trip.
So,
um,
she goes on stage and by the way,
don't ever asked me if my wife and my
friend's wife is hot.
That's rude.
It's put you on the spot.
You son of a bitch,
it'd be you.
She's very pretty,
but you handled it well.
Said she's pretty for regulatory.
So it wasn't like she was selling sex.
She was just selling funny,
you know,
she was going up there and being funny.
I mean,
she,
she doesn't,
she dresses like anybody.
Nice is.
I wouldn't say it was bad ass.
Try to be as respectful as possible.
Mr Mayor with all due respect.
And uh,
anyway,
she goes up there and I'm thinking,
man,
I just meet her right?
And she's with,
she's with Tom and I'm just like,
you know,
she seemed so nice now for sure.
She's going to go eat deck up there.
It's going to be terrible how you follow
the guy just beat a dude's ass with a
belt.
And everybody was screaming.
How do you follow it?
I took his pants down.
I want to say yes.
I want to say at the very least,
like his underwear was.
He had his underwear on and they beat
his ass with a belt.
Like he got fucked up.
I dude got hurt anyway.
Um,
she crush crush.
It just grabs it,
makes fun of it,
makes fun of the whole situation.
Relaxed gets two that gets to it on her
own due time.
Just controlled the whole room like a
pro.
It's so nice when you see that and be
like,
oh,
she knows what she's doing because
there's nothing worse than befriending
someone.
And then you know,
you've never seen them before and you
know,
it's like those,
those weird popping nights at the improv
where,
you know,
like a lot of times,
like on those Wednesday and Tuesday
night shows like this,
some of the people in the crowd will be
supporting the guy who was on stage and
they bring like 10 people with them.
Right?
Yeah.
You never know.
I brought a girl,
didn't bring her there,
but she was,
she lives in Chicago and the laugh
factory was in Chicago and I was doing
it.
She asked me if she could do some time
because her family's there.
I never even saw on stage.
She's hot.
Thank God.
Not only did she bring her family,
she put a shitload of people and she did
very well and she's really hot.
Wait a minute.
She's good.
I wouldn't say she's good,
but I mean she's probably not like an
Kristina's Kristina's class.
Christina present split.
Uh,
she did very,
very well.
I mean,
she's a newcomer,
you know,
she's really,
really green.
But I mean,
like all it was,
was just like me going,
yeah,
you're hot.
Fuck,
I'll do seven minutes.
What do I care?
You know,
who impressed me the most?
Uh,
doing like a pop into like that little
aster,
great Chicago theater down there was
3,400
people there or whatever the fuck it
seats.
It's more than 3000.
I don't know how many would say it's,
it's more than 3000.
She destroyed
that kid and yeah,
she's good.
She was funny on the podcast too.
There's so many
finally fucking people today.
This is crazy time.
Crazy time.
They came back,
you know,
I mean,
fuck yeah,
I did better.
I think it's better than ever.
I.
Yeah,
I really do like Kevin Hart.
I mean,
I'm think about,
uh,
Brian Cowen,
nick.
I mean Jim Brewer,
uh,
Bill Barber,
David David.
Tell Dave,
Chappelle.
Chris Rock,
Louis C,
k,
m a s,
tosh.
Just stop right there.
I mean,
look at how many guys are dealing with
there.
I mean.
Oh,
hey Patton Oswald.
You can't forget Patton Oswald.
He's one of the best.
There's so many good guys right now,
man.
There's so many fucking good guys.
No,
fuck.
It makes me laugh though,
even though he's not a traditional
standup.
Who?
Andy kindler.
Oh,
he's hilarious.
He kills me.
He has a traditional standup.
He says he just makes fun of standards.
It makes fun of.
It's.
Yeah,
like he does.
So when he bombed,
he does better than when he's doing
good.
Yeah.
No,
he's the funniest bomber ever.
He's awesome.
Yeah.
He's,
he's quite a character.
That guy.
Yeah.
We,
we live in good times.
This is a great time for comedy and you
know the fact that everybody has a
podcast now.
I think he's awesome.
I just think it's one of the most
amazing things ever that all these
different people have something that
connects to the act,
you know,
like you get to see the person,
like instead of just seeing the jokes on
stage,
you get to see the unfiltered human
being.
You know,
you get to see them fuck around with
shit.
Talking about serious shit.
Talk about not so serious shit.
Boss balls.
Be Silly.
It'd be a little ting.
So little this little that is it wrong.
Bring up somebody for yourself.
Squarespace.com.
Go there until you fucks
you fucking whore.
Mr.
I am supposed to like,
what is the squarespace squarespace url?
Yeah,
motherfucker.
Who is a fucker.
It was from philly.
No motherfucker.
Hume might've fucker.
He told me that a test she came in to
see as God daughter at the laugh factory
and I thought I was going to go up so he
agreed to do my radio show the radio
show there.
At the time,
two years ago,
excuse me,
and uh,
he goes,
yeah,
I says,
I'm not going on.
I'm tired.
He goes,
well,
if you're not going on,
I'm not fucking doing your podcast.
I said,
you don't do it.
He goes,
there goes my gun in his fucking a that
guy in restaurant in Vegas.
You pictures in a fucking yard.
I'm looking at.
Yeah.
I felt like a fucking fag looking at
you.
What?
I'm taking a piss at the Joe Patches
that or is this a joke?
No,
that's what he said.
Really?
Huh?
He said he felt like he was a fag.
She just pulled your cock out and see
what happens next.
Could you imagine if Joe Pesci just
started mowing down your cock?
No,
I can't.
Even if you're,
you know,
obviously you're not gay,
but even if you just for the
experiences,
what I'm saying,
that's a good point to keep in mind.
The next time we see him he brings it up
again.
While I was trying to figure out why he
was telling you that.
Well,
because my picture was up above the
urinal because he loves you.
Does Joe Pesci Cock in his hand and he
just killed so memorable?
You had to bring it up.
Did you have to fucking say that?
Squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe.
Use the code Joe Five.
Save yourself some money and a thank you
to onnit dotcom o n n I t use a codename
Brogan and save 10 percent off any and
all supplements.
Dominic motherfucking,
I rarer esquire.
Thank you sir.
Thank you.
You're the fucking man.
I am proud to be a friend,
my friend.
I'm honored and spend a lot of fun and
joy over the 20 years of knowing.
Yeah,
we've had a lot of good times.
My friends.
Oh yeah.
We plan on having more.
Alright,
you fucks a powerful Dan Hardee will be
here Wednesday.
It'll be an early podcast.
Uh,
11:00
AM on Pacific Time.
Four powerful Dan Hardee.
And then there will also be one on
Thursday.
And I'll let you know who's going to be
on that.
All you fox.
We love the shit out of you.
I appreciate you all.
And uh,
and mad love to you.
Big kisses.
Thanks Joe.